Hey Will, hello there, hey Sean, we only got some real sweaty pits today. Are you concerned about anything or are you just nervous? I just took a lie detector. Oh wow, and what was the result? I'm a liar. Anyway, this episode is going to be great. Yeah, we're going to work out some truth. Yeah, it's an all new smart list.
嘿，威尔，你好，嘿，肖恩，我们今天都满头大汗了。你是在担心什么，还是只是紧张？我刚测了谎。哦，哇，结果是什么？我是个骗子。总之，这一期节目会非常棒。是的，我们要找出一些真相。没错，这是一期全新的聪明人播客。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hot Mike. Hot mics. Hot mics.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。开着的麦克风。开着的麦克风。开着的麦克风。
Hi, hot mics. Hey, hi, hot mics. Um, hot mics. As soon as pixelable, your hot mics. Post-money page. I'd love to take a look at all your hot mics. Look at you. So tired. He's still. He's so tired.
嗨，开着的麦克风。嘿，嗨，开着的麦克风。嗯，开着的麦克风。一有机会，你们的麦克风就开着。后期的页面。我很想看看你们所有开着的麦克风。看看你。太累了。他还是。他太累了。
He's still got it. He's so tired. It's so tired. Sean, you had a hot bob once, didn't you? I had a hot, you know, I had a hot totty, hot bob and a hot mic. You ever had a hot bob haircut?
他宝刀未老。他太累了。太累了。肖恩，你以前留过热辣鲍勃头，对吧？我留过一个热辣的，你知道的，我喝过热托迪，留过热辣鲍勃头和开着的麦克风。你留过热辣鲍勃头发型吗？
Yeah, you did on the, what you'm gonna call it, Stooges Film. I had that shelf haircut in the 80s where you cut it. Of course. Did you really? Yeah, you buzzed. That sounds very to Pesh mode.
对，你在那个……叫什么来着……《三宝喜剧》里留过。我在80年代留过那种平头，就是剪成……当然。真的吗？对，你剪短了。听起来很有讨喜模式（Depeche Mode）的风格。
It's total. It's TDM total to Pesh. I had like, like, kind of long and then in short in the back. You know, you had it like covering one of your eyes. Yeah, just kind of like coming up, you know, Archie's kind of got that right? You're all just son there, listener. He's got, he's got a little bit of a, what's that?
完全是。那是绝对的讨喜（TDM）风格。我留那种，前面留得比较长，后面比较短。你知道的，那种刚好遮住一只眼睛的发型。对，就是那种往上梳的，你知道，阿奇（Archie）就留过那种，对吧？听众朋友，你儿子在那儿。他有点……那叫什么？
Kind of looking through there. Yeah, well, now it's kind of long all around. What's that? Yeah. That's a, what's that haircut of looking through there. Now it's kind of long all around. What's that? That's what's that haircut? Yeah. Yeah. I can't hear you because my hair's blocking my eyes, not my ears.
就从刘海缝隙里看东西的那种。对，现在四周都留长了。那叫什么？对。那种……从刘海缝隙里看东西的发型。现在四周都留长了。那叫什么？那是……什么发型？对。对。我听不见你说话，因为我的头发挡住了眼睛，不是耳朵。
It's a bit of an early, last thing he says to himself before he leaves, what's that? Yeah. Yeah. Our buddy Richard, the most incredible real estate broker in the world. He is so good. If you're looking to buy a home in Los Angeles area,
这有点像他离开前对自己说的最后一句话，那叫什么？对。对。我们的好友理查德，全世界最不可思议的房地产经纪人。他太优秀了。如果你想在洛杉矶地区买房，
especially in the west side of Los Angeles area. Tricky Dickie, Rick Ehrlich. Richard Ehrlich is your guy. Yeah, amazing. And he's also an OG super fan of smart loss. Yes, so hello to Richard, if you're listening. I need your turn. Richard's got a, Richard's got, I've made a board you with this
尤其是洛杉矶西区。狡猾的迪基，里克·埃利希。理查德·埃利希（Richard Ehrlich）就是你的不二人选。对，太棒了。而且他还是“聪明人播客”的超级铁粉。所以，如果理查德你在听的话，向你问好。轮到我了。理查德有一个……理查德有一个……我之前可能用这个烦过你，
before, he's got a mirror face like we all do, but he's got a, he's got a mirror face, like we all do. But he's got a, he's got a trigger sentence that launches that mirror face. You know, everyone's got a face that they use. Well, when you look in the mirror, when you want to look your best, like one last look to go out, you kind of tighten up the eyes and maybe turn your head a little bit. He had a right. Yeah, exactly. Right.. So what Richard does to prompt the mirror look he's looking for is he pretends that he is asking someone for directions, right? He's pulled up in his car and next to someone walking their dog, maybe, and he asked some directions and they give them the directions and he looks forward over steering wheel and
他有一张“照镜子脸”，就像我们大家一样，但他有一张……他有一张“照镜子脸”，就像我们大家一样。但他有一个……有一个能触发“照镜子脸”的特定句子。你知道，每个人都有一张自己常用的脸。嗯，当照镜子的时候，当你想要展现最好状态时，比如出门前的最后一眼，你会把眼睛稍微眯起来，头可能稍微歪一点。他有一套对的。对，完全正确。所以理查德为了摆出他想要的这种照镜子表情，他会假装自己在向某人问路，对吧？他把车停下来，可能停在某个遛狗的路人旁边，然后他向对方问路，对方指了路，然后他看着方向盘前方，
then he figures, well, man, we didn't hear it correctly. And he'll turn to his left to the person and he'll go, well, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man,
接着他想，好吧，伙计，我们没听清楚。然后他会向左转看着那个人，说，好吧，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，
man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man,
伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，
man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man, man just say, that's the new one, right? Yeah, he never looks hotter than when he says it's where. Which is so crazy, because he's such a nice guy. He's a nice guy, he's nice look in.
伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，伙计，就说，那是新出的，对吧？对，他每次说“那是哪儿”的时候，看起来都帅呆了。这太疯狂了，因为他是个超级大好人。他人很好，长得也好看。
But he's just, he's not good with directions. Sean, good morning. Good morning to you. What have you done so far today aside from putting on some smartless swag, I see there on your body? You know, he's always wearing smartless shit. Yeah. We're like, we're televising this and he's helping move merchandise.
但他就是……他方向感不太好。肖恩，早安。早安。除了穿上我看到你身上那套“聪明人”周边衣服之外，你今天还做了什么？你知道的，他总是穿着“聪明人”的破衣服。对。我们就像是在进行电视转播，而他正在帮忙推销商品。
I wear it because I really like it. Where I sleep in it. Hmm. He sleeps in it. Sean, what was the sleep schedule last night? Because you have a weird, you wake up in the night and then you go back to bed early in the morning. Yeah, I go to bed at midnight.
我穿它是出于真心喜欢。我甚至穿着它睡觉。嗯。他穿着它睡觉。肖恩，昨晚的睡眠时间表是怎样的？因为你作息很诡异，你会在半夜醒来，然后清晨又早早回去睡觉。对，我午夜上床睡觉。
I get up at about 3 a.m. I stay up until about six or seven, then I fall back asleep for a couple hours and I'm good to go. And then I need like a 10 minute nap. And then I'm good to go. Total chaos and then I'm good to go. I know.
我大约凌晨3点起床。我一直醒着到早晨6、7点，然后回床上再睡几个小时，这样状态就完全好了。然后我大概需要10分钟的小憩。接着状态就完全好了。完全是一团糟，然后状态就完全好了。我懂。
Oh, I know. Oh, what? Don't start doing will. It's total cash. How's it? How's it to email that three or four in the morning? I know. Oh, I know. Oh, I know. Oh, I Don't start doing will I love where your impression of me just has the dumbest look You know what we've done here Sean though. We've we've we've we've we've we boosted up young Willie Willie started this he started the pod a little bit down a little bit out of sorts Yeah, and then it's just a little bit of love.
哦，我懂。哦，什么？威尔，别开始学我。这简直是一团糟。给凌晨三四点发电子邮件感觉怎么样？我懂。哦，我懂。哦，我懂。哦，我……威尔，别开始学我。我太喜欢你模仿我时那副最蠢的表情了。你知道我们刚才做了什么吗，肖恩？我们……我们……我们把年轻的威利状态给调动起来了。威利刚开始录播客时有点情绪低落，状态不太在线，对吧？然后经过一番关爱，
And now the wings are flapping. All right, tighten up guests. Here we come today. We have a guest who's a giant in many categories. She's a Titan in music, acting, producing, philanthropy, business, and social media. If you wanted to describe a person who's uniquely suited to soar in today's media and cultural
现在他斗志昂扬了。好了，嘉宾们，打起精神来。我们这就开始。今天我们迎来了一位在许多领域都是巨星的嘉宾。她是音乐、表演、制作、慈善、商业和社交媒体领域的泰斗。如果要形容一个完美契合当今媒体和文化体系的奇才，
systems, you would simply say her name. I think that's right. She's a Grammy, Emmy, SAG, Golden Globe, and Critics Choice Nominative Musician, actress and producer. Her music is amassed 34 billion streams globally. She's got a movie coming out, a scene show that's already on, and a company that exceeds 300 million in sales annually. And when she's not running those things, she's keeping up with her 428 million followers
你只需念出她的名字。我想是的。她是一位获得过格莱美奖、艾美奖、美国演员工会奖、金球奖和评论家选择奖提名的音乐人、演员兼制作人。她的音乐在全球拥有340亿次的流媒体播放量。她有一部即将上映的电影，一部正在热播的节目，以及一家年销售额超过3.3亿美元的公司。当她不忙这些事情的时候，她还要应付Instagram上的
on Instagram. What else needs to be said, guys? Please welcome the lazy, unaccompanied, unmotivated, and perpetually failing Miss Alina Gomez. Woohoo! Woohoo! Wow! Oh, boy. Wow. and perpetually failing Miss Alina Gomez. Woo-hoo! Woo-hoo! Wow. Oh, boy.
4.28亿粉丝。各位，还用多说什么吗？请欢迎这位懒散、形单影只、缺乏动力且一事无成的赛琳娜·戈麦斯小姐！万岁！万岁！哇！天哪！哇！而那位一事无成的赛琳娜·戈麦斯小姐！万岁！万岁！哇。天哪。
Wow. I love the unmotivated, perpetually failing. It was so hard not to laugh. It was so hard. I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. Wow. Oh my gosh, Alina, hello.
哇。我太喜欢“缺乏动力、一事无成”这个形容了。刚才忍住不笑可真难啊。太难了。真的太抱歉了。我太抱歉了。哇。哦天哪，赛琳娜，你好。
Hi, guys. I'm so happy to be here. I'm so happy you're here. I'm so happy you're here. This is a very nice thing you're doing for us and our listeners. Oh, no. I'm just more more my thing. I'm so happy. No, it's pretty cool of you. If we didn't know, it looks like you were lying in bed and she's got, we have an overhand.
嗨，大家好。我很高兴能来到这里。很高兴你能来。很高兴你能来。你为我们和我们的听众做了一件非常好的事情。哦，不。这其实挺符合我的风格。我很高兴。不，你人真挺不错的。如果我们不知道的话，看起来你就像是躺在床上，而且她后面……我们有一个俯瞰视角。
Oh, yes. Well, that is my beautiful background that I made for you guys, because I figured that would be better than... You're keeping a real listener. Listen, she's got just a sheet draped over just a bunch of dead bodies behind you. Yeah, perhaps. Good work. Thanks. Nice second. I'm murders. Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。嗯，那是我为你们制作的美丽背景，因为我觉得这总比……你真是一个真正的听众。听着，她身后只是挂着一块床单，后面挂着一堆死尸。对，也许吧。干得漂亮。谢谢。不错的第二点。我是个杀人犯。哦，是的。
Well, we're going to get to that. We're going to get to that. So, Selena, where do we find you this morning? Are you in Los Angeles? I am. I am home right now. And I just had my coffee. And, yep. What time do you usually get up every morning? I'm a 630 guy. I am home right now and I just had my coffee and yep. What time do you usually get up every morning?
好吧，我们待会儿会聊到这个。我们待会儿会聊到这个。那么，赛琳娜，今天早晨我们在哪里能找到你？你在洛杉矶吗？是的。我现在在家。我刚喝过咖啡，然后，是的。你通常每天几点起床？我是个6点半起床的人。我现在在家，我刚喝过咖啡，然后，是的。你通常每天几点起床？
I'm a 630 guy. I'm about 730. Are there animals to feed? Yes, I have two dogs. You do? What kind? They're little multi-pues. They're pretty annoying, but cute. To the same.
我是个6点半起床的人。我大概7点半。有要喂的宠物吗？对，我有两只狗。真的吗？什么品种？它们是小玛尔济斯。挺烦人的，但很可爱。是一样的吗？
Is that because your body gets you up at 7 or you just lost your voice? No, my body does. I think I don't know. For some reason, maybe the show or something, it's just embedded in me or that I'm automatically up. And then I feel like a piece of shit if I wake up at like 10. Sure. Yeah.
是因为你的身体习惯让你7点钟醒来，还是你刚好失声了？不，是我的身体生物钟。我想……我不知道。可能是因为节目或其他什么原因，这种作息已经融入了我的身体，让我会自动醒来。如果我睡到10点左右才醒，我就会觉得自己是个废柴。确实。对。
Even though those are nice. What is that about the body that'll just wake you up at the same time every single day? Circadian rhythm. Circadian. We're rarveling at the body. Look at that. Yeah. And then if you just point it, and then if you point your eyes at something, it tells
尽管睡到10点也很舒服。身体究竟是怎么做到每天都在同一时间把你叫醒的？昼夜节律。昼夜节律。我们在为人体感到惊叹。看那个。对。然后如果你指着它，如果你把眼睛对准某个东西，它就会告诉
your brain what you're seeing. Huh. It's just you're like a one man Spielberg movie. Just a wonder. Yeah. Guys, if you put this in front of another, you'll just end up moving forward. That's incredible. All right.
你的大脑你看到了什么。哼。你简直就像是个一人分饰多角的斯皮尔伯格电影。简直是个奇迹。对。伙计们，如果你把这个放在另一个前面，你最终只会向前移动。太不可思议了。好了。
So, Celia, with these two dogs, they're multi-pues. Yes. So, that's a combo, right? That's a mix. Yes, they're very cute. They're brother and sister. No, they are. I got them at two different times, but they definitely don't act like brother and sister.
那么，赛琳娜，这两只狗是玛尔济斯犬。是的，所以这是一个组合，对吧？是一个混血品种？是的，它们非常可爱。它们是亲兄妹吗？不，不是。我是分两次领养它们的，但它们的行为绝对不像兄妹。
No. Rescue spear breads. We can cut that if you want. No, no, no, I actually, not afraid to say during COVID, I was very scared and lonely. And I found a one on Craigslist because the mom was like, we had babies that we don't know what to do. Yes, they're like, we don't know what to do.
不。救援纯种犬。如果你想的话，我们可以把这段剪掉。不，不，不，其实……我不介意在疫情期间说出来，当时我非常害怕且孤独。我在Craigslist（分类信息网站）上找到了一只，因为狗妈妈的主人说，我们生了一窝小狗，不知道该怎么办。对，他们就说，我们不知道该怎么办。
Our dog had puppy, so I was like, I'll take one. Clear, they're like, we don't know what to do our dog head puppy. So I was like, I'll take one. Clear out for a joke. Go ahead, Will. No, no, no, no. No, it actually was really sketchy though. They like drove in from Vegas and like rolled the window halfway down and passed me the dog and wanted the cash. I was like, all right, my my my my
我们的狗生小狗了，所以我想……我要一只。说清楚点，开个玩笑。说吧，威尔。不，不，不，不。不过那次经历其实真的挺诡异的。他们开车从拉斯维加斯赶过来，把车窗摇下一半，把狗递给我，然后就索要现金。当时我想，好吧，我……我……我……
did have a bad experience. I did have a bad experience once. He's got a guy posted on Craigslist. He said, who wants for a hundred bucks, you want to come on. Check out these puppies. And let me say when I got to his house, it was not dogs. Dogs. I'm not dogs. Come check out these puppies for a hundred bucks.
确实有过糟糕的经历。我确实有过一次糟糕的经历。有个家伙在Craigslist上发帖。他说，谁想要，给一百块钱，你可以过来看看这些小狗。我要说的是，当我到达他家时，那根本不是狗。狗。不是狗。过来花一百块钱看看这些小狗。
Thank you, Will. Thank you. You rest again. All right. Let's. Will tell you what are your own mouth. We're a little sloppy this morning. Super slabby. Selena, isn't it better to get this over with than then afternoon? No, no, I actually don't mind this. This is a great way to start my day. You guys are making me laugh.
谢谢你，威尔。谢谢你。你休息一下吧。好啦。威尔，管好你自己的嘴。我们今天早上有点散漫。超级散漫。赛琳娜，把这事儿在早上做完，是不是比在下午做要好？不，不，其实我不介意这个。这是开始我一天生活的好方法。你们俩一直在逗我笑。
Well, keeping these bents, not over yet. We'll, we'll let you revisit that at the end to see if you still love it. All right. Now, Selena, you're incredibly accomplished. You started very young. I want to know. So you started with acting. Yes, because mom was an actor and got you kind of
好吧，保持这种心态，还没结束呢。威尔，我们等节目最后再让你回顾一下，看你是不是还那么喜欢。好啦。现在，赛琳娜，你取得了极其辉煌的成就。你很小的时候就出道了。我想了解一下。所以你是通过演戏出道的？是的，因为妈妈是一名演员，这让你对……
interested in that. Yeah, she actually never pressured me or said that's what I should do. She just did a lot of theater growing up. So she never really did anything television-wise. And I was seven when I got my first job because I was only child super dramatic and I was like, I'm so capable of this. And I do. Kind of all it takes. Yeah, I really, but it worked and I've just been working every sense and I feel lucky. Was this Barney? That was Barney. That's crazy. You're starting with Barney. Yes. That's a pretty, right? The guy who played Barney, he was pretty hot.
产生兴趣了吗？对，她其实从未向我施压，也没说过我应该做什么。她在成长过程中演过很多戏剧。所以她其实从来没有涉足过电视领域。我七岁时得到了第一份工作，因为我是个独生女，超级戏剧化，当时我想：我完全能胜任这个。我确实做了。这差不多就是全部过程了。对，真的，但它奏效了，从那以后我一直在工作，我感到很幸运。这是《巴尼与朋友》吗？那是《巴尼与朋友》。这太疯狂了。你以《巴尼》出道。对。那挺……对吧？扮演巴尼的那个人，他挺帅的。
Was he? Yeah, he was hot. He had to be like fit and like cute because he was wearing this like, he doesn't have to be dead, but he was. He was a Barney. Hot Barney. This is changing everything. He knew Doc.
是吗？对，他很帅。他必须保持健美和可爱，因为他穿着这个……他虽然不需要长得像死人，但他确实很帅。他是巴尼。性感巴尼。这颠覆了一切。他认识Doc。
So he was a plushie, yeah. Uh-huh. Oh, I'm sorry, Sean. Was that just quick for Tracy really quick? Just break it down. Tracy need to know this. Is she want to know what a plus she is? A bunch of these like a fetish where people dress up in like costumes and stuff, right? No, I heard you guess.
所以他是个毛绒玩具，对吧？嗯哼。哦，对不起，肖恩。刚才那是为了快速向崔西解释吗？就顺便解释一下。崔西需要知道这个。她想知道什么是毛绒玩具吗？毛绒玩具是不是一种恋物癖，就是人们穿成各种服装之类的，对吧？不，我听到你猜了。
What do you mean, right? You don't need to say right question mark to us. Yeah. Like we're going to hear something or something or that is correct, Sean. All right. So we're with Barney and and we're having fun on that, and then, how did Barney happen? I really want to know. It was, yeah, it was like a little thing,
你什么意思，对吧？你不需要对我们说“对吧，问号”。就像我们会听到什么或是那种情况，或者你说得对，肖恩。好啦。所以我们聊到巴尼，我们在那上面玩得很开心，然后，巴尼是怎么发生的？我真的很想知道。那是……对，那只是一个小插艺，
but I was in line with 1,400 people on a hot Texas day, and my mom was like, are you sure you want to do this? I was like, yeah, I'm fine. Because you knew what TV was, and you thought it'd be cool to me. Yeah, I mean, my mom wasn't very Intense about what I could watch so I would stay up and watch friends with her and Willing Grace and
但我在德克萨斯州炎热的一天里和1400个人一起排队，我妈妈问我：“你确定要这么做吗？”我说：“行，我挺好的。”因为你知道什么是电视，而且你觉得上电视会很酷。对，我的意思是，我妈妈对我看什么节目并不是非常严格，所以我经常熬夜跟她一起看《老友记》还有《威尔和格蕾丝》，以及……
That was like what I grew up with Barney and Willing The longest time by the way on my bio on Instagram says I love willing grace No way that's a sweet thing. Yeah, after like a solid year and then everyone was like, can you maybe change that? I was like, that's very sweet. Did you ever see the episode where, where, uh, uh, Will was in a dance-off with, uh, Sean and Jackson, with Janet Jackson? You did? I was a back, with Bill.
我就是伴随着《巴尼》和《威尔和格蕾丝》长大的。顺便说一句，我在Instagram个人简介上写了很长一段时间“我喜欢《威尔和格蕾丝》”。真的吗，太可爱了。对，在保持了一整年后，每个人都问：“你能不能把它改掉？”当时我想：这多可爱啊。你有没有看过那一集，威尔和肖恩·杰克逊以及珍妮·杰克逊一起进行舞蹈对决？你看过吗？我当时是伴舞，和威尔一起。
I played it back at dancer. Oh, that's right. And then Karen got mad because she fell for you. And yes, I get her. Oh, my God, you really are a fan. Wait. Well, I remember you snapping those moves. I think I was there that night, right? You really know how to finish a move. Remember how it really was hard point, but we're so tired. And Jimmy's like, okay, let's do it again. I looked at Sean. I'm like, I do it again. But, but Salina, do you know just as'm like, five six. But, but, Salina, do you know just as a, as a Will and Grace superfan, you know, that we,
我扮演伴舞。哦，对。然后凯伦生气了，因为她看上了你。没错，我懂她。哦天哪，你真的是个铁粉。等等。威尔，我记得你跳那些舞步的样子。我想我那天晚上也在场，对吧？你真的很懂怎么完成一个动作。还记得当时真的很严格，但我们太累了，吉米说：“好吧，我们再来一次。”我看着肖恩，心里想：我还要再来一次。但是，赛琳娜，你知不知道作为……虽然我身高五尺六寸。但是，赛琳娜，你知不知道作为一个《威尔和格蕾丝》的超级铁粉，你知道我们……
there's a podcast that Sean does called Just Jack and Will that he does with Eric McCormack? No, I do know. I actually do know. And I remember like, my friends sent me the link because she knew that I was obsessed and I had no idea. Oh, yeah.
肖恩和埃里克·麦柯马克（Eric McCormack）做过一个播客节目叫《只是杰克和威尔》（Just Jack and Will）吗？不，我知道。我其实知道。我记得……我的朋友把链接发给我，因为她知道我迷这个，而我当时还一无所知。哦，真的吗。
Yeah. Sean, did you know that Salina Gomez was such a huge Will and Grace fan? I did because I'm really good friends with Marty Short. Oh, yes. And then we chatted on the phone, me and Selena chatted on the phone like a year ago or something, and you were like, oh my god.
对。肖恩，你知道赛琳娜·戈麦斯是《威尔和格蕾丝》的超级大粉丝吗？我知道，因为我和马蒂·肖特（Marty Short）是好朋友。哦，是的。然后我们通了电话，我和赛琳娜大约在一年前左右通过电话，当时你就说：“哦天哪。”
And I was like, oh my god. I know I freaked out. And then I was like, oh my god. And she was like, no, likewise. Selena, I'm a huge fan. That's kind of a bit of a meat cue. No, I'm very excited. I like what. Like what. With you, so. Me too. And I grew up. No, I'm very I'm very excited. I like
然后我说：“哦天哪。”我知道我当时吓了一跳。然后我说：“哦天哪。”她说：“不，彼此彼此。”赛琳娜，我是你的超级粉丝。这有点像是一次刻意的安排。不，我非常兴奋。我喜欢……就像……和你一样，所以。我也是。我长大了……不，我非常……非常兴奋。我喜欢……
class with you. So me too. And I grab now 53, 53. All right. So we do or we're we're galloping along with with acting. We've got the Barney under our belts. We'll move into Waverly place. Yes, my Disney show. Yes. And and a few other jobs here and in there and things are really moving and cooking. Yeah. And then there's a cooking show later, we're going to get to that. But when did music start to start to tap you on the shoulder and say, hey, come this way?
和你一个阶层。所以……我也是。我长大了……现在53岁了，53岁。好啦。所以我们……我们在表演的道路上策马奔腾。我们有了《巴尼》的经历，接下来我们要进入《少年魔法师》（Waverly Place）。对，我的迪士尼节目。是的。还有中间零星的一些其他工作，一切都在顺利推进。对。后面还有一个烹饪节目，我们待会儿会聊到。但是，音乐是什么时候开始向你抛出橄榄枝，对你说“嘿，来这边”的？
Well, I think that Disney is safe to say they're a machine and they kind of, in a way, not forcefully required that I know how to sing so I could seem like the theme song like they know how to package someone and like make it of like a whole triple threat thing. This was happening during Waverly? Yeah so they asked me to do the theme song and I had fun with that and then they were like, would you like to do an album? And I thought it would be fun and I thought more than anything it would be like a hobby that I really enjoyed and then I wanted to be a serious actress. I was 15. And I wanted to be an actress. I'd never really intended on being a singer full time, but apparently that hobby turned into
嗯，我觉得迪士尼可以说是一个流水线工厂，他们在某种程度上——倒不是强迫——但要求我知道怎么唱歌，这样我才能唱主题曲。他们知道如何包装一个人，将其打造为全能艺人。这发生在《少年魔法师》拍摄期间吗？是的，所以他们让我唱主题曲，我在其中玩得很开心，然后他们问：“你想出一张专辑吗？”我觉得这会很有趣，而且比起别的，我觉得这更像是一个我真的很喜欢的爱好，当时我还想成为一名严肃的演员。我当时15岁。我想成为一名演员。我从来没打算过全职当歌手，但显然那个爱好演变成了
something else. Yeah, you're doing all right. Now, did you do have any idea that you could sing before you tried it? Yeah, well, I was on Barney, and I do I love you. You love me. Well, that's not very challenging. And you know, it warmed up my vocals.
其他的东西。对，你现在做得很好。那么，在尝试之前，你知道自己会唱歌吗？对，嗯，我在《巴尼》里唱过《我爱你，你爱我》。好吧，那没什么挑战性。而且你知道的，那热身了我的声带。
Okay, all right. There you go. And then because of that, did you take like singing lessons and and develop your instrument, as they say? You know, I did. I don't think I'm the best singer, but I think I know how to tell stories. And I love being able to make songs that, you know, I get more like a, I always get people coming up to me saying, I had no idea it was you that was singing that song and that kind of makes it feel nice to me that I feel like it's just about the song. I mean withers of Waverly Place was a gigantic show. Yeah I miss it. You do. I want to say my sister wrote on that for a second. Really? She was a writer on that maybe. I might not be right. But it was it was a blast like I will say.
好吧，好吧。那就对了。然后因为这个，你有没有上过唱歌课，去发展你的“乐器”，正如他们所说的那样？嗯，我上过。我觉得自己不是最好的歌手，但我认为我懂得如何讲故事。而且我喜欢能够创作这样的歌曲，你知道，我经常听到有人走过来对我说：“我根本不知道那首歌是你唱的。”这让我觉得很开心，因为我觉得这首歌本身最重要。我的意思是，《少年魔法师》是一部非常巨大的节目。对，我很想念它。真的吗。我想说我妹妹曾为它写过剧本。真的吗？她可能曾是那里的编剧。我可能记不太清了。但那确实是一段欢乐的时光，我得说。
Yes that's why I love sitcom. Would you say you have a good memory, Jason? No, not really. Okay. Wayne, we're going to get right back to you but Salina, I want to the so what is it? It's will. Thank you Scott. So, guys the bits. I love the bass. I love it. We'll be right back. Hey, smartless listener, it's Sean.
是的，这就是我喜欢情景喜剧的原因。杰森，你觉得你记性好吗？不，不太好。好吧。韦恩，我们马上就会回到你身边，但是赛琳娜，我想把……所以是什么？是威尔。谢谢你，斯科特。所以，各位，这些段子。我太喜欢这些梗了。我太爱了。我们马上回来。嘿，“聪明人播客”的听众朋友们，我是肖恩。
And I've got to share this scoop on something I'm really vibing with lately. Viori. It's not just workout gear. It's a whole new perspective on performance apparel. Imagine gear that's so versatile you can rock it for workouts, yoga, or just kicking it back on the weekend. I know you've heard me talk about it a million times, but I love it. Now, let's talk comfort. Viori is seriously in a league of its own. I'm telling you, right now I have on the core jogger, I love it, I sleep in it, don't tell Scotty.
我要和大家分享一个我最近非常喜欢的宝藏品牌：Viori。它不仅仅是健身装备，更是对高性能服装的全新诠释。想象一下，这种装备功能如此多样，无论是健身、瑜伽，还是周末放松，你都可以轻松驾驭。我知道你们听我唠叨过无数次了，但我就是爱不释手。现在，来谈谈舒适度。Viori真的是独树一帜。我告诉你们，我现在身上穿着的就是他们的Core慢跑裤，我太爱了，我甚至穿着它睡觉，千万别告诉斯科特。
And I always wear the Strato Tech T's. I love them. They're so soft and comfortable. I'm not like, you know, they're not clinging to my body. I love it. I could sleep in them and I do, and I go to the store and I do. Ready for the good stuff? Viori is an investment in your happiness and they're hooking up smart list listeners
而且我总是穿着Strato Tech T恤。我超爱它们。它们是如此柔软舒适。它们穿在身上不会紧紧贴着身体，我超爱。我可以穿着它们睡觉，我确实也这么做，我去商店也穿着它。准备好迎接好消息了吗？投资Viori就是投资你的快乐，他们现在为“聪明人播客”的听众提供专属福利：
with 20% off your first purchase at Viori.com slash smart list. That's VU-ORI.com slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping and any U.S. orders from $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smart list and discover US orders from $75 and free returns. Go to viewori.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of viewori clothing. Hey smartless listener, we are supported by Mint Mobile. On average, it takes about 30 days
在Viori.com/smartlist购买首单即可享受8折优惠。网址是 VU-ORI.com/smartlist。你不仅可以享受首单8折优惠，还可以享受任何美国订单满75美元免运费以及免费退货服务。快去 Viori.com/smartlist 探索吧，美国订单满75美元免运费并享受免费退货。前往 viewori.com/smartlist，探索 Viori 服饰的百搭魅力。嘿，“聪明人播客”的听众朋友们，本期节目由 Mint Mobile 赞助支持。平均而言，一个人打破新年愿望大概需要30天
for a person to break their New Year's resolution. So if saving money was on your 2024 list, your odds aren't looking that great. Luckily, I have 100% guaranteed way to save you money this year. Just switch to Mint Mobile. For a limited time, wireless plans from Mint Mobile are $15 a month when you purchase a three-month plan that's unlimited talk, text, and data for $15 a month. Mint Mobile is here to rescue you with premium wireless plans for just $15 a month.
的时间。所以，如果省钱在你的2024年愿望清单上，那你的胜算看起来不太妙。幸运的是，我有一个100%保证能让你今年省钱的方法。只需转投 Mint Mobile。限时优惠，Mint Mobile 的无线套餐每月只需 15 美元，当你购买三个月的套餐时，即可享受每月 15 美元的无限通话、短信和流量服务。Mint Mobile 来拯救你了，优质无线套餐每月仅需 15 美元。
Say, bye-bye to your overpriced wireless plans, jaw-dropping monthly bills, and unexpected overages. All plans come with unlimited talk and text, plus high-speed data delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Use your own phone with any Mint Mobile plan and bring your phone number along with all your existing contacts.
跟过时的昂贵无线套餐、令人瞠目结舌的每月账单以及意料之外的超流量费用说再见吧。所有套餐均包含无限通话和短信，并通过全美最大的 5G 网络提供高速流量。你可以将自己的手机用于任何 Mint Mobile 套餐，并带上你的手机号码以及所有现有的联系人。
Ditch overpriced wireless with Mint Mobile's limited time deal and get premium wireless service for just 15 bucks a month. To get this new customer offer and your new three-month unlimited wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month, go to MintMobile.com slash Smartless. That's MintMobile.com slash Smartless. Cut your wireless build of 15 bucks a month and show your support for the show at MintMobile.com slash Smartless.
借助 Mint Mobile 的限时优惠，摆脱价格高昂的无线服务，以每月仅仅 15 美元的超低价格享受优质无线服务。要获得这项新客户优惠以及你的全新三个月无限无线套餐，每月仅需 15 美元，请访问 MintMobile.com/Smartless。网址是 MintMobile.com/Smartless。将你的无线话费降至每月 15 美元，并通过 MintMobile.com/Smartless 表达你对本节目的支持。
Additional taxes fees and restrictions apply cement mobile for details. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So you guys knew you're right, 2024. You're thinking about resolutions. What could I do to improve myself? How could I do better? And then what happens is if you're like me, sometimes you write those resolutions and you focus on those and you hyper focus on those so that you overdo it, so then you fall out of it, whatever it's like eating better or exercising, or whatever the thing is, so you need to pull back and find balance so that you don't overdo it or don't do it at all.
附加税费和限制条件适用，详情请咨询 Mint Mobile。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。你们都知道，对吧，2024年到了。你正在考虑新年愿望。我能做些什么来提升自己？我怎么才能做得更好？然后发生的情况是，如果你跟我一样，有时你写下了那些愿望，然后把注意力集中在上面，过度关注，以至于用力过猛，结果半途而废，无论是吃得更健康、锻炼身体，还是别的什么事情，所以你需要放慢脚步，找到平衡，这样才不会用力过猛，或者干脆什么都不做。
Like, the hardest part is trying to find the balance, right, in the middle, and that's what therapy can do for you. It's done it for me and really, really help me focus and find balance so that I don't overdo it one way or the other. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule.
就像，最难的部分是试图在中间找到平衡，对吧，而这正是心理咨询能为你做的事情。它为我做到了这一点，并且真正、真正地帮助我集中注意力并找到平衡，这样我就不会走向任何一个极端的过度。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活的服务，并完美契合你的时间安排。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Celebrate the progress you've already made because at BetterHelp.com slash smartless today, to get 10% off your first month, that's betterhelp.hlp.com slash smartless. And now back to the show.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的心理咨询师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。庆祝你已经取得的进步，今天就访问 BetterHelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受 9 折优惠，网址是 betterhelp.hlp.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。
All right, so then you know that you can kind of sing a little bit and the music starts to take off. Like, I guess what I'm asking is what at what point was the acting and the music at the same level and you thought, do I have to pick or should I try to keep both these things up? at what point was the acting and the music at the same level? And you thought, do I have to pick? Or should I try to keep both these things going at the same speed?
好啦，既然你知道自己其实能唱一点歌，而且音乐事业也开始起飞。我想问的是，在哪个时间点，演艺事业和音乐事业达到了相同的平衡点，让你开始思考：我是必须二选一，还是应该努力把这两件事都继续维持下去？在哪个时间点，演艺事业和音乐事业达到了相同的平衡点？让你开始思考：我是必须二选一，还是应该努力以相同的速度把这两件事都继续维持下去？
I started having a lot of fun with music and then touring was really fun. But I was doing my TV show at the same time. And it wasards and I just, I found it really fun. So I just kept going, but the older I get, the more I'm kind of like, I would like to find something to just settle on. Yeah, well, it's exhausting, right?
我开始觉得音乐很有趣，然后巡演也真的很有趣。但我当时在拍电视剧，两者兼顾。虽然很难，但我发现它真的很有趣。所以我一直坚持下来，但年龄越大，我越是觉得：我想要找一样东西彻底安定下来。对，这真的很耗费精力，对吧？
I mean, that sounds like super, that's so hard. I just think about the energy of this such an old thing. Oh my God, I went to a mental institute and canceled one of my doors. Really? Yeah. Because it was so exhausting.
我的意思是，听起来超级……这太难了。我只要一想到这种能量，这就已经是老黄历了。哦天哪，我去了一家精神疗养院，取消了一场巡演。真的吗？对。因为实在太累了。
Yeah, it just got to me, because I love working, and it distracts me from bad things. And I like that. So I just like working. I was just saying that this morning. By the way, it reminds me my three-year-old Denny. He calls Lizards, because he can't say Ellie calls him Wizards. So he's like, we just me my three-year-old Danny. He calls Lizards because he can't see Ellie calls him Wizards. So he's like, there's a wizard in the backyard. I really
对，这真的压垮了我，因为我热爱工作，工作能分散我对糟糕事情的注意力。我喜欢这种感觉。所以我就是喜欢工作。我今天早上还在说这个。顺便说一句，这让我想起我三岁的儿子丹尼。他把“蜥蜴”（Lizards）叫作“小精灵”（Wizards），因为他发音不准，把“莉”（Ellie）也叫作“小精灵”。所以他说……刚才我和我三岁的儿子丹尼在一起。他把蜥蜴叫作小精灵，因为他发音不准，把莉叫作小精灵。所以他说，后院里有一个小精灵。我真的
hope there's a wizard in the back room. I'm talking in. But Selena, you're saying that in a perfect world, you would pick either one or the other going forward. Well, I do feel like I have one more album in me, but I would probably choose acting. You would. Yes. God damn you're so great at music though. Yeah, I mean, here's the good news. You don't have to pick. Don't have to pick. You're right, but I am gonna want to chill because I'm tired. But yeah, I mean, reading through, I can tell you, we've had some very accomplished people on this show.
希望后院里有个小精灵。我在说……但是赛琳娜，你的意思是，在理想世界里，接下来你会二选一？嗯，我觉得我体内还有最后一张专辑的存货，但我可能会选择演戏。你会的。是的。天呐，你在音乐方面也太优秀了吧。对，我的意思是，好消息是：你不用二选一。不用二选一。你说得对，但我确实会想要放松一下，因为我累了。不过，说实话，翻看这些资料，我必须告诉你，我们节目上接待过很多非常有成就的人。
Thank you listeners for making it a place where accomplished people want to come. I have never read so much information about a guest than I have about you. I mean, the things you have done in your, I mean, you're just barely 30, aren't you? 31. 31. It's just so admirable what you've done. It's a mind-on-line. It's a mind-on-line.
感谢听众朋友们把它变成了一个有成就的人都想来的地方。我还从没读过哪个嘉宾的资料像你这么多。我的意思是，你在……你才刚满30岁吧？31岁。31岁。你所做的一切真的太令人钦佩了。这简直不可思议。这简直不可思议。
It's a mind-on-line. In philanthropy and in global sort of charities and being in what a uniceph ambassador. So, the uniceph ambassador. And now I have my own foundation. It's just stunning. And we haven't even gotten to Rare Beauty, this beauty company, the makeup company. What do you call it? Rare Beauty.
这简直不可思议。在慈善事业、全球性慈善组织方面，作为联合国儿童基金会亲善大使。所以，联合国儿童基金会亲善大使。现在我有了自己的基金会。这简直太惊人了。而且我们还没聊到 Rare Beauty，那个美妆公司，化妆品公司。你叫它什么？Rare Beauty。
Yeah, but I mean, what would you describe it as a beauty company? I would say cosmetics. You know, it's been really fun, but we're actually starting to get into skin now. I know this is all girly stuff, but I I'm excited. I'm wearing makeup right now. Yeah, exactly. I know, but but we're going into skin now. It's about three years old and it's honestly been the biggest gift because I launched it during COVID and it just took off and I couldn't be more thankful. So did you launch it during COVID because you had time to finally,
对，但你会把它描述为一家美妆公司吗？我会说是化妆品公司。你知道，这真的很有趣，但我们现在实际上开始涉足护肤领域了。我知道这些都是女孩子的东西，但我……我很兴奋。我现在就化着妆呢。对，没错。我知道，但……我们现在要进军护肤领域了。它已经创立大约三年了，老实说，这真的是我收到的最大礼物，因为我是在疫情期间创立它的，它一下子就火了，我对此无比感激。那你是在疫情期间创立它的，是因为你终于有了时间，
because you weren't on tour and you weren't shooting, you're like, now I have time to dedicate to this or landing, can you come up or is it some of you always? It sucked. I was supposed to release it like a month right into COVID. So I had done all the promotion and everything. It's about to come out and then we figured,
因为你不用去巡演，也不用拍戏，所以你想：现在我有时间专注于这个了，赛琳娜，你是怎么想出来的，还是说这是你一直以来的想法？太糟糕了。我本打算在疫情爆发大约一个月的时候推出它。所以我已经做完了所有的宣传和一切准备。它正准备上市，然后我们琢磨着，
all right, we'll just try online. And I think makeup became really big during COVID because people would do the videos and they would create looks and it kind of just took off. And I'm always like confused and just grateful because I've never been the type of person that want. I don't want to be or need to be the number one anything. And I think that's what my mom has instilled in me,
好吧，我们就在网上试一试吧。我觉得化妆品在疫情期间变得非常火爆，因为人们会拍视频，创造各种妆容，然后它就这么火了。我总是感到既困惑又感激，因为我从来都不是那种想成为……我不想也无需成为任何事的第一名。我想这是我妈妈灌输给我的理念，
because I don't feel like anything is a competition. So I feel like there's room for everyone. Everybody, yeah. I'm really proud. Do you think like it's, when you started Barney at seven and then Wizards and then all that, do you think that your work ethic and your drive and your ambition was instilled in you or would have happened to anyway?
因为我觉得任何事情都不是一场竞赛。所以我觉得每个人都有发展的空间。每个人，是的。我真的很自豪。你觉得——当你七岁开始拍《巴尼》，然后是《少年魔法师》以及所有这些经历时，你觉得你的职业道德、内驱力和雄心是被培养出来的，还是无论如何都会发生？
Oh, I don't know. I'm probably would have been a hot mess if I wasn't doing a mess already. But I don't know. I don't know. I mean, obviously tell us. Obviously tell us how. I mean, oh obviously tell us. I mean, we obviously tell us how. Oh, I've been to like four treatment centers.
哦，我不知道。如果我当时没有做这些，我可能早就成了一个彻头彻尾的烂摊子了。但我不知道。我不知道。我的意思是，显而易见，告诉我们吧。显然告诉我们怎么……我的意思是，哦，显然告诉我们怎么……我的意思是，我们显然会讲讲怎么……哦，我去过大约四个疗养中心。
Just because of depression and anxiety, right? Yeah, yeah. And I'm bipolar as well. Well, you've got. Carry on top. And I would say you've got an incredible dynamic head on your shoulders that takes a lot of management and
只是因为抑郁和焦虑，对吧？对，对。而且我还有双相情感障碍。好吧，你还有……双喜临门。我想说，你拥有一个极其敏锐清醒的头脑，这需要大量的自我管理和
An analysis and it sounds like you're doing a pretty frickin good job Yeah, thank you. Thank you. I don't know Disney was like boot camp, you know, they were definitely Problems, you know doesn't have problem slena dummies I mean, it true. I mean, that's true. It's a blissful ignorance. That's where it comes from You need to be really smart to be complicated. Yeah, and I'm pretty, I don't know. I can be like, I think you're doing great. It's not getting in your way of your accomplishments. And you and I have talked a few times,
剖析，听起来你做得相当他妈的不错。是的，谢谢你。谢谢你。我不知道，迪士尼就像是新兵训练营，你知道的，那里确实有问题，你知道，迪士尼没问题赛琳娜傻瓜们！我的意思是，真的。我的意思是，这是真的。这是一种幸福的无知。这就是它的来源。你需要极其聪明才能把事情搞得这么复杂。对，而我挺……我不知道。我可以像……我觉得你做得棒极了。这并没有妨碍你的成就。你和我聊过好几次，
you're incredibly nice. So your personal success is fantastic as well, as opposed to your business success. So whatever you're doing, keep going. You're appreciate it. Are you super tight? So your mom, as you said, your mom is or was an actress and kind of that sort of paved the way for you to get into it and take it seriously.
你人真的超级好。所以你的个人成功和你的商业成功一样棒，无论你在做什么，继续保持吧。我很感激。你跟家里人关系超好吗？所以正如你所说，你妈妈是或者曾经是一名演员，这某种程度上为你铺平了道路，让你能够认真对待这件事。
And you mentioned your not only child, imagine you're pretty still pretty close with your folks. to how to imagine you're still pretty close with your folks. Yes. And was that like, when you started to make that transition into becoming a star at a really young age, what was that dynamic like with your folks? Like how much did you rely on them to kind of be there? And how has that relationship changed as you've gotten older?
而且你提到你是独生女，可以想象你和家人的关系应该还是很亲密。可以想象你和家人的关系应该还是很亲密。是的。当你在极小的年纪开始向明星身份过渡时，你和家人的这种动态是怎样的？比如，在很大程度上，你有多依赖他们陪伴在你身边？随着你年龄的增长，这种关系发生了怎样的变化？
I mean, do you notice? Yeah, I think when I was younger, my mom, I mean, my mom was my mom, I was under 18. So I was getting invited to these events and stuff. And my mom, from a very early age, was like, you're going to walk the carpet, maybe we'll stay for five minutes, but then adult times are probably going to happen.
我的意思是，你注意到了吗？是的，我觉得自我小的时候起，我妈……我的意思是，我妈就是我妈，当时我不到18岁。所以我被邀请参加各种活动什么的。我妈妈从很小的时候就对我说：“你要走红毯，也许我们会呆五分钟，但接下来大概就是成年人的社交时间了。”
And it was like the vanity fair parties and all that stuff. Right. So she was always very protective of me, but it never really felt like it was suffocating. And she would always say the same thing to me. She said, the moment you stop having fun, stop. It's okay. You know, like you, you don't need to just kill yourself over, you know, something. Yeah, because of the hour. Right. And the hours of people don't understand that the hours and hours and hours of work that it takes to do a TV show, a tour, whatever it is, or a movie.
就像名利场派对之类的所有那些场合。对。所以她一直非常保护我，但这种保护从来没有让我觉得窒息。她总是对我说同样的话。她说：“当你不再觉得开心的时候，就停下来。没关系的。你知道的，你不需要为了某种东西而把自己往死里逼。”对，因为那些时间。对。人们不理解拍摄一部电视剧、进行一次巡演、或者拍一部电影，需要耗费成百上千个小时的工作。
It's just like for a- It's hard enough to be a kid. I just think about it my own kids and being young teenagers, my older boys and I'm just thinking about it. And the younger ones with the speech problems. Right. I was looking for wizards. Wizards.
这就像对于一个……当孩子已经够难了。我只要一想到我自己的孩子，他们还是青少年的年纪，我的大儿子们，我就会这么想。还有那些有语言问题的小儿子们。对。我当时在找小精灵。小精灵。
It's like the idea of them, like Sean, we were over there watching the movie the other night with Archie. Can you imagine Archie's 15 being on the road and working all the time? I think like, no, he wouldn't be able to, he wouldn't be happy. He was about Selena saying,
就像想象他们……肖恩，我们前几天在那儿和阿奇一起看电影。你能想象阿奇15岁时在路上奔波、没日没夜地工作吗？我想……不，他不会的，他不会开心的。关于赛琳娜刚才说的，
oh, he had tough, right? Yeah, no, it is. And the transition honestly happened around 25 where I didn't feel like I had to impress my parents more so. But my mom was also really cool because right after Disney she put me in a movie called Spring Breakers. Like she found that movie and it's very, very, very fun.
哦，她经历过艰难时刻，对吧？对，不，确实如此。而且这种转变老实说发生在25岁左右，当时我不再觉得我需要更多地去向父母证明自己。但我妈妈真的很酷，因为就在迪士尼之后，她把我送去拍了一部叫《春假》（Spring Breakers）的电影。她找到了那部电影，那真的是一段非常、非常、非常有趣的经历。
Yeah. Very, very sweet. Very. But it was fun. Yeah, and it was it. I mean, I'm sure your mom was not strategic with grabbing that nor were you. But I'm sure that there was some thought put into it where this would sort of broaden the public's idea about that which you can do and that which is fitting of when they think about you, she can do this, she can do that. And or was it just a part of like, well this is a little bit closer to who she's starting to become, not somebody who's... My mom was a huge harmony current fan and she heard there was a script out and so she was interested in it and the character I play is an as-ray see.
是的。非常非常甜美。非常。但这很有趣。是的，而且就是它。我的意思是，我确信你妈妈拿那个并不是出于什么策略，你也不是。但我敢肯定，里面还是有些心思的，这会拓宽公众对你的看法，也就是你能做的事，以及当他们想到你时觉得合适的事——她能做这个，她能做那个。或者这只是像是，嗯，这更接近于她开始成为的那种人，而不是那种……我妈妈是哈莫尼·科林（Harmony Korine）的超级粉丝，她听说有一个剧本出来了，所以她很感兴趣，而我扮演的角色是一个……
So I was like 19 when I did it. And she just came up to me and she was this will make no sense. And you're probably gonna think I'm crazy, but just read this. And I read it and I don't know. I gravitated towards the character. And then I met Harmony and I was like, oh, game over. He's just really cool.
所以我拍的时候大概19岁。她就走到我面前，说这可能毫无意义。你可能觉得我疯了，但就读读这个吧。然后我读了，我不知道。我被这个角色吸引了。然后我遇到了哈莫尼，当时我就觉得，哦，游戏结束了。他真的很酷。
How did your mom have the sense to know good material from bad material or the right material? She's really great at that stuff. She found the book 13 Reasons Why, which we turned into a TV show. So she randomly was at a bookstore and she was in young adult and found that and we developed it.
你妈妈怎么会有那种眼光，能分清好剧本和烂剧本，或者说找到正确的剧本？她在这方面真的很厉害。她发现了《十三个原因》这本书，我们把它拍成了电视剧。所以她当时随便在一家书店的青少年读物区转了转，就发现了它，然后我们对其进行了开发。
She just has really nice taste, you know. And instincts, clearly. It's, yeah, she's really great. So I like to ask her advice on things. That's great, awesome. Yeah, I love that you guys are so close. Yes. You know, we can cut this part too,
她就是品味很好，你知道的。而且直觉很准，显然。这，是的，她真的很棒。所以我喜欢就各种事情向她征求意见。太好了，棒极了。是的，我很喜欢你们俩关系这么近。是的。你知道，这部分我们也可以剪掉，
but I am fascinated and thankful for how, I've spoken to you about mental health. Because I have somebody very, very close to me who I've had to deal with it and not deal with it, but just like help with it. Yes. And, but do you, you say thank you to him. You've never publicly thanked him.
但我对你是如何看待这一点的感到既着迷又感激，我跟你聊过关于心理健康的事。因为我身边有一个非常非常亲近的人，我不得不去面对它，也不是说去对付它，而只是去提供帮助。是的。但是，你，你对他说过谢谢吗。你从来没有在公开场合谢过他。
No, I was going to say the same thing. All jokes aside, Jason, you dick. I was going to say, oh, no, JK, I was going to say, I like the way, I like the way that you're so open and frank about that, about mental health. And I think that it's something that people, luckily, talk about more and more, but I think it's really refreshing to hear you talk about it in a way that's very, just sort of matter of fact in, and I think it's really, I don't know, it shows real maturity and it shows, I think it's very brave. And I think it helps so many people
不，我正要这么说。不开玩笑了，杰森，你个混蛋。我本想说，哦，不，开玩笑的，我本想说，我喜欢这种方式，我喜欢你对心理健康如此开放和坦诚的态度。我认为这是人们——幸运的是——越来越多地谈论的事情，但我认为听到你以一种非常、就事论事的方式来谈论它，真的让人耳目一新，并且我认为这真的，怎么说呢，展现了真正的成熟，而且我认为这非常勇敢。并且我认为它帮助了那么多的人，
the way that you talk, honestly, in that way. I really did struck me. I think it's really remarkable. It is, it's great. Because my mom died of Alzheimer's a long time ago. I forget when, and because of his injuries over. Because it was so painful. Because it was so painful, I just, me and my sister and my family,
以你那种坦诚的方式交谈。真的深深触动了我。我认为这真的很了不起。确实，这很棒。因为我妈妈很久以前死于阿尔茨海默病。我忘了是什么时候，而且由于他受了伤，因为太痛苦了。因为太痛苦了，我只是，我和我姐姐还有我的家人，
we would... There's a point where you have to start making it funny. Yeah. Because you've cried too much about it. So then you cut it with humor. And the funniest, you know, Alzheimer's story is like ever. Because I lived through it.
我们会……有时候你不得不开始把它当成笑话。是的。因为你为它哭得太多了。所以你用幽默来化解它。而最搞笑的，你知道的，阿尔茨海默病的故事简直是绝无仅有。因为我亲身经历了。
And it was so tragic that, you know, my mom... We can cut this too. But my mom would go to the bathroom, she'd go number two in the toilet, and I'd walk in there, I'd go, mom, you have to flush the toilet, she goes, I don't know who did that, I don't know who that is, they came in here and I was here, they went to the bathroom. No, we could not prove that that's mine. We could not prove that that's mine. And we would laugh because it was past the point. So my question is, have you, me dealing with somebody with my girlfriend? I'm not proved that that's my, and we would laugh because it was past the point.
而且它是如此悲惨，以至于，你知道，我妈妈……这部分我们也可以剪掉。但我妈妈会去洗手间，她在马桶里大号，然后我走进去，我说，妈妈，你得冲马桶，她说，我不知道那是谁干的，我不知道那是谁，他们来到这里，而我在这里，他们去上洗手间了。不，我们无法证明那是我的。我们无法证明那是我的。我们会笑，因为事情已经过去了。所以我的问题是，你，我怎么对付一个有这种情况的女朋友？我没有证明那是我的，我们会笑，因为它已经过去了。
So my question is, have you, uh, me dealing with somebody with that? Have I taken a shit and forgot? No, no, no, have you ever, no, have you ever, like, I've ever just kind of infused humor into the whole situation. Definitely. Um, I also have a few friends that are, you know, in comedy and writers and it's it's just fun, you know, and now me and my family are in a place where we can do that. And I don't mind saying the things that I'm walking through and they can be fun and they can be messy.
所以我的问题是，你，呃，我怎么和患有这种病的人相处？我是不是拉了屎却忘了？不，不，不，你有没有，不，你有没有，比如，我有没有把幽默融入到整个情况中。绝对有。嗯，我还有几个朋友是喜剧演员和编剧，这很有趣，你知道的，现在我和我的家人处在一个可以做到这一点的境地。我不介意说出我正在经历的事情，它们可以是有趣的，也可以是一团糟的。
But I've always- Did you take the power back? Yeah, I just out knowing, but I've always. They take the power back. Yeah, I just know more. I feel better. And it gives so many people, myself included, a little bit more comfort in the reality that I'm not, you know, I'm kind of broken upstairs. We all are.
但我一直——你把主动权夺回来了吗？是的，我只是在了解情况的同时，但我一直——把主动权夺回来了。是的，我只是了解更多了。我感觉好多了。这也让很多人，包括我自己，对“我其实并没有……你知道的，我的脑子有点坏掉了”这个现实感到了一点点安慰。我们都一样。
There are as many mental variables in all of us as there are physical ones. You can see the physical ones. Someone's taller, someone shorter, someone's thicker, someone's thinner, someone's got bigger feet smaller feet. Like, there are their equal number of variables in the brain and the fact that we've got medicine, therapeutics, an environment that is tolerant of all of those variables nowadays, as opposed to back when our parents were our age. Is that right?
我们每个人体内的心理变量和生理变量一样多。你能看到生理变量。有人长得高，有人长得矮，有人胖，有人瘦，有人脚大脚小。就像，大脑中的变量数量是相等的，事实上我们现在有了药物、疗法，以及一个能包容所有这些变量的环境，而不是像我们父母年轻的时候那样。对吗？
And Jason, on top of that community, the idea that you're talking about it, Shedselite says, you're not alone, there's somebody else, and somebody else can relate to that and identify with it. Certainly, I know for my own life, and I can go, like, and somebody else says, I have this and they go, oh, and they talk about their experience and I go,
而且杰森，除此之外，谈论这个社区的理念，你所谈论的， shedding light，这说明，你并不孤单，还有其他人，还有人能对此感同身受并产生共鸣。当然，我知道在我自己的生活中，我可以去，比如，当另一个人说我有这个，他们会说，哦，然后他们谈论他们的经历，我说，
oh, you have this too. And then we can talk about it in a way that, and that kind of really breaks it wide open. It definitely, it connects you as well. I mean, that's why I released my documentary. It's all based on mental health. Which was incredible. Yeah, I haven't seen it.
哦，你也有这个。然后我们可以用一种方式来谈论它，这真的把话题彻底打开了。这绝对能让你产生共鸣。我的意思是，这就是我发行纪录片的原因。它完全基于心理健康。太不可思议了。是的，我还没看。
I'm so, forget me. No, I, it's, no, pause rate. We're gonna watch it. I'm, no, me. I'm gonna watch that. No, I want to see it. No pause rate. We're gonna watch it. I'm gonna get on here. But it ends well. I just, I think that's why I did the documentary. I was terrified before it came out.
我太——忘了我吧。不，我，这，不，暂停一下。我们要看。我，不，我。我要去看。不，我想看。不暂停一下。我们要看了。我要上这个。但结局很好。我只是，我想这就是我拍纪录片的原因。在它上映之前我吓坏了。
And I had already signed a contract. And I was like, damn, I can't go back. But that was a really big moment for me. And then I had people coming up to me not saying like, oh my god, can I have a picture? They would say I've dealt with depression or I've done this and then I end up having a connection with people. Yeah, I love that. Sometimes with all my health stuff like I've had a kidney transplant, I have high blood pressure. I gosh, I have mental, mental health and I don't even know.
而且我已经签了合同。当时我想，该死，我不能回头了。但这对我来说是一个非常重大的时刻。然后有人走过来对我说，不是那种“哦天哪，我能拍张照吗？”他们会说我曾与抑郁症作斗争，或者我经历过这些，然后我最终与人们建立了联系。是的，我很喜欢这样。有时由于我所有的健康问题，比如我做过肾移植，我有高血压。天哪，我有心理健康问题，我甚至不知道。
I'm sure I have other problems that I'm not aware of. I love talking about all of them. You can think about like a situation and say, why me, why me? And instead, it's given me the gift to say, oh, I know why it's me. I'm there for those people that are going through what I went through. And I can say, I hear you and I see you. Not just be in and say, my life's perfect, what I went through. And I can say I hear you and I see you, not just be in and say my life's perfect, but I'm sorry, you know, it's like,
我确信我还有其他自己不知道的问题。我喜欢谈论所有这些。你可以回想一下某种情况，然后说，为什么是我，为什么是我？相反，它给了我一个礼物，让我说，哦，我知道为什么是我了。我在那里陪伴那些经历过我所经历的事情的人。我可以对他们说，我听见了，我看见了。不仅仅是身处其中却说，我的人生很完美，我所经历的——我可以对他们说我听见了，我看见了，不仅仅是身处其中却说我的人生很完美，而是我很抱歉，你知道，就像是，
well, I can be honest with you. I'm a big believer that the person upstairs, or whomever's upstairs for anybody, doesn't give you anything more than what you can handle. Yes. And so the fact that you've been given all of these gifts, challenges, and that you're able to go through them so successfully in a public space, such that you can give encouragement and support and to others is like, I mean, talk about using your years right. We've talked about it on the show before, about when you get to the end,
嗯，我对你很坦诚。我坚信楼上那个人，或者对任何人来说不管谁在楼上，绝不会给你超出你能承受的事情。是的。所以，你被赋予了所有这些天赋、挑战，并且你能够在一个公众视野中如此成功地度过它们，以至于你能给其他人带来鼓励和支持，这就好比，我的意思是，谈论如何正确利用你的岁月。我们在节目中讨论过，当你走到终点时，
you're gonna, we're all gonna look back and hope that we used our time correctly. I mean, the first 30 years of your life have been incredibly accomplished. Like 20 lives, mentally, certainly. Yeah, I guess the question really is slated now, what? Yeah. You know, you're fixing your brain,
你会，我们所有人都会回首过去，希望我们正确利用了时间。我的意思是，你生命中的前30年取得了令人难以置信的成就。从精神层面上讲，绝对像经历了20种人生。是的，我想现在真正的问题是，接下来呢？是的。你知道，你在修复你的大脑，
you're fixing the world. Yeah, I don't know. I think I just, I gravitate towards things I connect to. And I'm all about authenticity. I can't really force myself to be anything than who I am. And it's just, you know, luckily worked. It's about your ability to recognize and attract those who are equally authentic is really keen too.
你在修复世界。是的，我不知道。我想我只是，我被我能产生共鸣的事物所吸引。我全心追求真实。我真的无法强迫自己成为除了我自己之外的任何人。而且，你知道，幸运的是这奏效了。关键在于你识别并吸引那些同样真实的人的能力也非常敏锐，
You know, like I'm just thinking when you're talking about the documentary and thinking about Alec Asixian and his sister, Aline, we both work with. I mean, people like that, like you probably have a great team around you, great friends around you, like all of us as we get older, you have less and less friends, but that's usually by choice. Talk to us about your ability to kind of pick up on people's uniqueness and authenticity
你知道的，就像我在想当你谈论纪录片时，想到了亚历克·阿西西安（Alec Aksian）和他的妹妹阿琳（Aline），我们俩都跟他们合作过。我的意思是，像这样的人，你身边可能有一个很棒的团队，一群很棒的朋友，就像我们所有人在变老的过程中一样，你的朋友越来越少，但这通常是你的选择。跟我们谈谈你那种能够察觉到别人的独特性和真实性的能力，
you're lacking thereof. Is that something you always had or has it just gotten sharper? And maybe it has gotten sharper, but ever since I was younger, I like to think I had good discernment with people. And I could just sense when I felt that it was being forced or that there was something they were wanting or whatever, I just could feel that in a lot of people. And I mean, obviously I put some of those people in my life when I was younger,
或者缺乏这种特质的能力。这是你一直都有的，还是变得更加敏锐了？也许确实变得更加敏锐了，但从我很小的时候起，我愿意认为我对人有很好的辨别力。我能感觉到什么时候我觉得它是勉强的，或者他们有所求什么的，在很多人身上我都能感觉到。我的意思是，很明显我在年轻的时候把一些这样的人带进我的生活里，
and then I later realized, but most of my friends, like I said, they're, I mean, they can go from being a writer to one of my friends is a real, one of my friends is a realtor. So, like I kinda... Is that Richard Arleic? I kinda just... It's not Richard Arleic, is it? No.
然后我后来才意识到，但我的大多数朋友，就像我说的，他们，我的意思是，他们可以从一个作家变成我的一个朋友是个地产经纪人，我的一个朋友是个地产经纪人。所以，我有点……那是理查德·阿尔莱克（Richard Arleic）吗？我有点只是……那不是理查德·阿尔莱克吧？不是。
Yeah, well, it's's having people skills, right? And I wonder if you're like me, that's part of what has always attracted me to being an actor is because I'm just fascinated with people. And I really enjoy reading people and seeing is this a person a match for me or not? And I just wonder what that is. Also, it's just staying curious, right?
是的，好吧，这需要人际交往能力，对吧？我想知道你是否跟我一样，这也是吸引我成为演员的部分原因，因为我对人着迷。我真的很喜欢观察人，看看这个人是不是和我合得来。我只想知道那是什么。还有，就是保持好奇心，对吧？
Yeah. The moment you stop being curious, then like Jason just said, you become one of those dummies. Yeah, no, I love life and I love people. And I find it really fun. Do you find that which do you find is more cathartic for you, more sort of a lane to explore and enjoy parts of you, is it with playing different characters or being a songwriter?
是的。你停止好奇的那一刻，就像杰森刚才说的，你就变成了那些傻瓜之一。是的，不，我热爱生活，我热爱人们。我发现这真的很有趣。你觉得哪一个对你来说更具宣泄作用，更能探索和享受你的一部分，是扮演不同的角色还是成为一名词曲作者？
I think it's a little bit of both. I wrote this ballad called Luzy to Love Me and that was probably the most personal song I'd ever released about something that was on everyone's mind for some reason. And then in acting, I feel like I have these moments in my life that have happened and I'm able to use that and it actually feels great. And it feels like after a good cry or something, it's like a good feeling. Is there something that you, I mean, this is going to be one of the dumbest questions you've ever got? Is there something with every single thing that you've done? We're just like, you know what, I've never done. I want to, I
我觉得两者皆有。我写过一首名为《Lose You to Love Me》的民谣，那可能是我发行过的最私人的歌曲，关于某种出于某种原因每个人都在想的事情。然后在大我演戏时，我觉得我生活中的这些时刻发生过，我能够利用这些，它实际上感觉很棒。这种感觉就像痛哭一场之后什么的，是一种很好的感觉。有没有什么事情，我的意思是，这可能是你听过的最蠢的问题之一？你所做过的每一件事中，有没有什么事情是让你觉得，你知道吗，我从来没做过。我想，我
need to do that before. Oh, yeah. I don't think I've even began like in a lot of areas. Like I, not necessarily cosmetics and stuff, but like I've said many times with you guys, I think acting. I don't think I've been able to even touch the surface of what I know that I'm capable of doing. I'm very selective or else I'd be in all of the movies that I get offered. I just fight for my roles and I'm always auditioning, so I like to earn it. Yeah, that's great. We'll be right back. Smartless listener, if you like to laugh, and I hope so,
需要在之前做那个。哦，是的。我觉得我在很多领域甚至都还没有开始。就像我，不一定是化妆品之类的，但就像我跟你们说过很多次的那样，我认为演戏。我不认为我甚至触及了我所知道的我能够做到的事情的表面。我非常挑剔，否则我会出演所有找到我的电影。我只是为我的角色而战，我总是在试镜，所以我喜欢靠自己赢得它。是的，那太棒了。我们马上回来。Smartless的听众们，如果你喜欢笑，我希望如此，
this year catch two hilarious comedies starring two legendary Johns, John Leraket, in the new season of Nightcourt, and John Cryer in his new comedy Extended Family. Tuesday nights on NBC, the laps are never in short order. When New York's most outrageous court gets back in session, it's America's number one comedy, Night Court, starring John Lerichette.
今年来看看两部搞笑喜剧，由两位传奇约翰主演：约翰·拉洛奎特（John Larroquette）主演的新一季《夜间法庭》（Night Court），以及约翰·克莱尔（John Cryer）主演的新喜剧《温馨大家庭》（Extended Family）。每周二晚在NBC播出，笑声绝对不会间断。当纽约最离谱的法庭再次开庭时，这就是全美排名第一的喜剧《夜间法庭》，由约翰·拉洛奎特主演。
And after that, catch John Crier in a great new comedy about life and family after divorce, it's Extended Family. Also starring the amazing Donald Fazon and Abigail Spencer. Laugh more in 2024 with two fantastic comedies, Night Court and and extended family, starring John Larraquette and John Cryer,
在那之后，收看约翰·克莱尔主演的一部关于离婚后的生活和家庭的精彩新喜剧《温馨大家庭》。该剧还由迷人的唐纳德·法森（Donald Faison）和阿比盖尔·斯宾塞（Abigail Spencer）主演。2024年，通过两部精彩的喜剧《夜间法庭》和《温馨大家庭》收获更多笑声，主演是约翰·拉洛奎特和约翰·克莱尔，
Tuesday's UnNBC. Hey, Smartless Crew, I've been drinking AG1 since 2020. It's become my daily go-to foundational nutrition supplement. Really, I trust AG1 because it's not just about what's in it, but what's not, catch my drift. AG1 is rigorously tested for 950 impurities way beyond the industry norm. Seriously, it's a game changer for me.
每周二在NBC播出。嘿，Smartless的伙伴们，我从2020年开始就一直在喝AG1。它已经成为我日常首选的基础营养补充剂。真的，我相信AG1是因为它不仅在于里面有什么，更在于里面没有什么，懂得我意思吧。AG1经过了严格的测试，可检测950种杂质，远超行业标准。说真的，它对我来说是个彻底的改变。
I feel the difference daily. What I love about it is it's so easy. You can make it smoothie and just dump it in with all the other stuff in your smoothie or you can just mix it with water and take it on the go. And your body's getting all the vitamins and minerals that you could possibly need. Instead of taking a bunch of supplements and buying all that healthy food that you have to eat,
我每天都能感受到不同。我喜欢它的一点是它太简单了。你可以把它做成奶昔，把它倒进你奶昔里的所有其他东西里，或者你可以只把它和水混合，随时随地饮用。你的身体正在获取你可能需要的所有维生素和矿物质。与其吃一堆补充剂并购买所有你必须吃的健康食品，
it's just AG1 all in one drink. Now, let's get into the good stuff. Why AG1? It's a powerhouse for major body systems with ingredients like vitamin C and zinc, which helps me make my immune health and tip top shape. AG1 is the supplement I trust to provide the support my body needs daily, and that's why they've been a partner for so long. If you take just one thing, let it be AG1. Try AG1 and get a free one-year supply of item in D3K2 and five free AG1 travel packs with your first purchase. Go to drinkag1.com slash smartless
不如直接来一杯AG1。现在，让我们进入正题。为什么选择AG1？它是维持主要身体系统的强效武器，含有维生素C和锌等成分，这有助于将我的免疫健康保持在最佳状态。AG1是我信赖的补充剂，能够为我的身体提供日常所需的营养支持，这就是为什么他们能成为这么长时间的合作伙伴。如果你只吃一样东西，那就选AG1吧。尝试AG1，并在首次购买时获得一年份免费的维生素D3K2以及五包免费的AG1旅行装。访问drinkag1.com/smartless
so they know we set you. That's drinkag1.com slash smartless, check it out. Thank you, Stitch Fix for supporting this episode. Hey, are you still clinging to the same old jeans and hoodies from Fall? If you're ready to level up your winter wardrobe, but the uncertainty of sizing it online shops has you feeling lost, a Stitch Fix stylist can help you with a new winter wardrobe tailored just for you. Stitch Fix is an easy way to get clothes that fit you without having to endlessly browse through options
好让他们知道是我们介绍的。那是drinkag1.com/smartless，快去看看吧。谢谢Stitch Fix支持本期节目。嘿，你还在紧抓着秋天那些老旧的牛仔裤和连帽衫不放吗？如果你准备升级你的冬季衣橱，但在线购物尺码的不确定性让你感到迷茫，Stitch Fix的造型师可以帮你打造量身定制的全新冬季衣橱。Stitch Fix是一种简便的方法，无需无休止地浏览各种选择
or break the bank. Think of them as your style partner. Your stylist will learn about your taste and collaborate with you on looks you love. With your choices in mind and a wide range of sizes available from XS to three XL, they'll find your perfect fit and send you clothes hand-picked just for you. They have over 1,000 brands and styles
或花光积蓄，就能买到合身的衣服。把他们当作你的时尚伴侣。你的造型师会了解你的品味，并与你合作打造你喜爱的造型。考虑到你的选择，并提供从XS到3XL的广泛尺码范围，他们会找到最适合你的尺码，并为你精选专属于你的服装。他们拥有1000多个品牌和款式，
and do the work of choosing the best options for you. They'll even show you how to wear head to toe outfits so you can just get dressed and go. And if you don't love something, just send it back. Shipping returns and exchanges are always free. You know, look, you can always go online and just click and order clothes, but how cool is it to get a personal stylist
并为你挑选最佳选择。他们甚至会教你如何搭配从头到脚的服装，这样你就可以直接穿上出门。如果你不喜欢某些东西，只需退回即可。运费、退货和换货永远都是免费的。你知道的，你可以随时上网点击订购衣服，但找一个私人造型师来帮你出谋划策并把衣服搭配在一起，因为我在行这方面太糟糕了，这该有多酷。我以前在一家零售公司工作，我总是把衣服搭在一起，但对顾客来说没有一件是搭配的。现在我有了这个，这太棒了。我希望我能有这个来帮我。谢谢Stitch Fix，他们真的懂我，
to help you come up with ideas and put clothes together because I'm horrible at it. I used to work at a retail company and I would put clothes together all the time and none of it matched for customers. And now I get this, this is so great. I wish I had this to help me. Thanks StitchFix, they just get me
他们也会懂你。今天就访问StitchFix.com/smartless试用吧，当你保留fix中的所有衣物时，即可享受25%的折扣，网址是StitchFix.com/smartless。StitchFix.com/smartless。slash smartless stitchfix.com/smartless。现在回到节目中。我越来越充满热情的一件事，不再是去扮演各种角色，而只是去扮演
and they'll get you too. Try today at StitchFix.com slash SmartLess and you'll get 25% off when you keep everything in your fix, that StitchFix.com slash SmartLess. StitchFix.com slash SmartLess. slash smartless stitchfix.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Something I've sort of really gotten more and more passionate about is not playing characters as much as just playing
某个不需要让我做太多表演和扮演角色的人，我有点喜欢做观众。这很大程度上源于我内心的渴望：在生活中尽量做到不扯淡，不虚伪、不搞笑、不假装成其他人。所以我真的很喜欢尽量做到真实。当你想到演戏时，你是否有过类似的挣扎？因为你非常擅长做真实的自己、安于现状并且诚实，这难道不与我们作为演员努力去做的事情背道而驰吗？
somebody that doesn't force me to do a lot of acting and play a character, I kind of like to be the audience. And a lot of that comes from my desire to try to be as not full of shit as possible in my life and not be fake and funny and pretending to be other people. So I really like trying to be as authentic as I can. Do you have a similar sort of battle when you think about acting because you're so good about being really you and being in your skin and being honest, it does that run counter to the whole thing
有点像，但我刚刚拍完这部电影，这部雅克·欧迪亚（Jacques Audiard）的电影，全片都是西班牙语，而且是一部音乐剧，这是我做过的最具挑战性的事情之一。但这真的，这部电影叫《艾米莉亚·佩雷斯》（Emilia Perez），我想明年会上映。如果你刚才说“关你屁事”，那就太好了。我对这部电影很兴奋，因为比如有这样一个场景，我正在被抛弃，我没有透露任何剧透，我记得我将自己代入了第一次去戒毒所时不得不离开的那一刻，我记得我告诉我的联合主演，
that we try to do as actors? Kind of, but I just finished this movie, this Jacques Radeard film and it's all in Spanish and it's a musical and it was one of the most challenging things that I've done. But it's really, Emilia Perez, I think that will come out next year. It's so good if you just said none of your business. I'm excited for that because for example there's the scene where I'm being left and I'm not giving anything away and I remember I channeled the moment when I had to go to rehab for the first time and leaving and I I remember I told my co-star
那就是我当时的感受，我觉得当我回想起那第一个时刻并感到恐惧时，把那种情绪释放出来感觉真的很好。这很酷。所以感觉真的很有宣泄作用。说到这个，你有没有想过要去，你知道我要问什么，去百老汇或者演现场戏剧？或者也许你已经演过了。
That's what I was feeling in the moment and I just felt like it was getting that out when I remembered that first moment and being terrified. That's cool. So it felt really cathartic. Speaking of that, have you ever wanted to go to, you know what I'm gonna ask, go to the Broadway or do live theater? Or maybe you have.
我还没有。我想我愿意去。我不确定我是否准备好了，因为我觉得我可能还是会有点紧张。哦，真的吗？是的。巡演过后，你已经是一个舞台表演者了。不，但这不一样，因为我喜欢做我的演唱会，因为那感觉就像是，
I haven't. I think I would like to. I'm not sure I'm there yet, because I think I'd still be a little nervous. Oh, really? Yeah. After touring, you've'd still be a little nervous. Oh, really? Yeah. After touring, you've already been like a stage performer. No, but it's different, because I love when I'm doing my concert, because it's like,
哦，这些都是我的铁粉。对，对，对。你觉得舒服。你觉得更安全，对，对，肯定是的。好吧，你能多谈谈那个吗，关于这种挣扎，因为当我必须公开演讲时，我变得非常紧张，我甚至连祝酒都做不到。真的吗？是的，他的脸会变白。
oh, these are my peeps. Right, right, right. You feel comfortable. You feel safer, yeah, yeah, for sure. Well, will you talk more about that, about battling, because I get very nervous when I have to speak publicly like I can't even give a toast. Really? Yeah, he goes white.
真的。是的，但当涉及到其他要面对公众的事情时，我有着无比的自信。面对成百万上千万人的镜头。面对数百万人，而不是餐桌旁的10人。所以我不理解自己身上的这一点，拥有巨大自信和零自信之间的区别，这其实是类似的事情。你怎么样？
That's true. Yeah, but I have an enormous amount of confidence when it comes to other things that are going to be made for the public. A million kinds of camera. From millions of people as opposed to 10 people at a dinner table. So I don't understand that about myself, the difference between having a lot of confidence or zero confidence that are sort of similar things. How are you doing?
因为你在生活中那么会说话，仅仅是，我的意思是，很显然在生活中，这就是为什么让我大跌眼镜的是，在任何有晚宴派对的时候，或者大约两三年前，我们在理查德家举办的你的生日晚宴上。是的。我说，让我们在房间里转一圈，说说我们有多感激，我们有多爱杰森，我先来，我站起来，发表了这篇小演讲，
Because you're so well spoken in life, just, I mean, clearly in life, that's why I blows my mind that anytime where like a dinner party was, or like two, three years ago, we are at your birthday dinner party at Richard's house. Yeah. And I said, let's go around the room and say, how grateful, how much we love Jason, and I'll start, and I got up, and I gave this little speech,
轮到的时候，你说，我退出。我不想参与这事。就像今晚一样。是的。但是，是的，你是如何应对这种状况的？就像，当你能够站在，你知道的，十万人的面前开演唱会，或者拍一部将要面对成百上千万人观看的电影或电视节目，
and it got to, and you were like, I'm out. I don't want any part of this. It's like tonight. Yeah. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like, what is that switch that flicks for you It's like good-bye. But yeah, so how do you manage that? Like what is that switch that flicks for you when you can stand up in front of, you know, a hundred thousand people and give a concert or do a movie or a television show that's going
与比如第一次去约会或为杂志做采访相比，到底是什么触发了你心中的那个开关，无论是什么带给你焦虑，你知道那个不同的东西是什么吗？因为我还在试图在自己身上弄明白这一点。嗯，我想当我年轻的时候，我过着非常非常公开的生活，在很多方面这并不公平，以至于我达到了这种程度：如果我不在谈论发生了什么，每个人都会继续替我叙述我的人生，而人们就会全盘接受。我需要人们听到我自己的声音。我真的不再在乎了。
to be from millions of people versus like maybe going out on a date for the first time or doing an interview for a magazine or whatever might give you anxiety, do you know what that is, that different thing? Because I'm still trying to figure it out with myself. Well, I think when I was younger, I had a very, very public life and it wasn't fair in a lot of ways that I got to the point so much so that I was like, if I don't talk about what's going on, everyone's going to continue to narrate my life and people are just going to buy it. And I need people to hear from me. And I genuinely stopped caring.
就像，我不在乎，我。我会很乐意站起来，对某人高度赞扬。我很乐意这么做。即使我搞砸了，我也觉得，好吧，那太逊了。但是，你知道，我尽力了。我想，没关系。所以我不知道我是不是只是，我做这件事太久了，但我已经失去了一点那种恐惧。但我还是会有蝴蝶在胃里飞的感觉。
Like, I don't, I don't care. Like, I would be happy to stand up and speak very highly of someone. I'd be happy to do it. Even if I mess up, I'm like, all right, well, that sucked. But, you know, I tried. I'm like, it's fine. So I don't know if I'm just, I've done it for too long, but I just have lost a little bit of that fear. But I still get the butterfly feeling.
是的。所以也许我只是习惯了，然后我有点像，哦，人们会喜欢它或者不喜欢它。是的，我有一个朋友，玛丽亚·施赖弗（Maria Shriver）。她，你知道的，我认识她很多年、很多十年了。她，每当我
Yeah. So maybe I just got used to it, and then I'm kinda like, oh, people are gonna like it or not. Yeah, I have a friend of mine, Maria Shriver. She, you know, I've known her for years and years and decades. And she, whenever I would have dinner at her house, she's the one who forced me to get up and talk like that. And it's so, I was littered, you know,
对啊。所以也许我只是习惯了，然后我就觉得，随便吧，人们会喜欢或者不喜欢。对，我有一个朋友叫玛丽亚·施赖弗。她，你知道的，我认识她很多年、很多十年了。她呢，每当我到她家吃晚餐时，就是她逼我站起来那样讲话的。这真的是，我当时觉得，你知道的，
sorry, I was riddled with fear about it. And, but she forced me to do it. She's like, we're gonna go around and stand up and speak how you feel. And I was like, pass. I'm going to the next part. Were you so nervous that you would just littered?
对不起，我对那件事充满了恐惧。但是，她逼我这么做的。她说，我们要四处走走，站起来说出你的感受。而我想说，跳过。我要去下一部分。你当时紧张得直冒汗吗？
Is that what you're saying? I'm like, I'm having a tough time following what happened. But Jay, Marie, okay. But now that you're saying it, I think like for me, it's like I'm afraid of being accused or judged as either being full of shit or being stuck up. I think I had a real complex about being conceited and stuck up when I was in middle school.
你是这个意思吗？我觉得，我有点难理解到底发生了什么。不过，杰，玛丽，好吧。但现在你这么说，我觉得对我来说，就像我害怕被指责或评判为满口胡言或是高傲自大。我觉得我在初中时对自负和清高有一种很深的情结。
Like, 67th grade was really hard for me in school because people, oh, here comes that guy on TV. He stuck up. So I wasn't really, I was shy about being confident because people would think I was stuck up. So then I tried to seem not confident and then maybe that part of me kind of took hold. But what's crazy about that though is think about it.
比如说，六年级对我在学校来说真的很难，因为人们……哦，电视上那家伙来了。他很傲慢。所以我其实并不是……我很羞于表现自信，因为人们会觉得我很高傲。然后我就尽量表现得不自信，接着可能我身上的那一部分就占据了主导。但最疯狂的是，你想想看。
That's inauthentic. Yeah, exactly. If you think about it, you fell victim of the very thing that you were trying to prevent. I mean, that honestly. And when you're thinking about it that much, you put a space between you and people you're trying to connect with.
这太不真实了。对，完全是这样。如果你仔细想想，你成了你自己极力想要防范的那种事情的受害者。我是说，老实说。当你想得那么多时，你就在你和你想交流的人之间拉开了一段距离。
Jay, I really mean it. And if you can break that down and react in real time, then it will never be inauthentic. But the second you start thinking about, you're trying to curate what other people think of you, that's inauthentic. Yeah, and that makes me so nervous because I'm having to manage two things
杰，我是认真的。如果你能把它分解并在实时中做出反应，那么这就绝不会是不真实的。但就在你开始思考、试图策划别人对你的看法的那一秒，那就是不真实的。是的，这让我非常紧张，因为我必须处理两件事
at the very same time. Right, right, because you're taking care of their feelings before yours. Yeah, you're never gonna be able to before you are. Yeah. Yeah, you're never going to be able to, I remember somebody saying, you can't tell everybody how to treat you or how to look at you. There's nothing you can do about the way people think about you. Yeah, you can do stuff.
在同一时间。对的，对的，因为你总是把他们的感受放在你自己的感受之前。是的，你永远不可能在照顾好自己之前……是的。是的，你永远不可能，我记得有人说过，你无法告诉所有人该如何对待你或如何看你。对于别人怎么看你，你什么也做不了。是的，你可以做点什么。
You can do stuff. Well, yeah, there's that and also like, you'll never, you'll never get to. Celina, one second. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's okay. I'm enjoying this.
你可以做一些事情。嗯，是的，有那个，而且就像，你永远不会，你永远不会去。赛丽娜，等一下。好吧。好吧。不，没关系。我很享受这个。
I like that conversation. But really, just really quick, it's the same thing that I've cared around for so long being gay is like, I've caught my entire life. I just came out. My entire life, I've been, I spent taking care of other people's feelings and putting my second. And then you have to reach a point where Salina is saying,
我喜欢这个对话。但说真的，非常简短地说，这和我一直以来非常在意的事情是一样的，作为同性恋就像是，我一辈子都在抗争。我才刚刚出柜。我一辈子都在，我花时间去照顾别人的感受，把自己的感受放在第二位。然后你必须达到塞琳娜所说的那个时刻，
we're like, I can't, I'm exhausted. But why did you do that for other people? With regards to you being gay, is that what you mean? Yeah, yeah, with, like, if I enter a room, even today, I still have a little bit leftover, but for the most part, I don't care. It's like, I have to check, like, I'm so used to, it's in my blood now to check how people think about me entering a room. Are they thinking about my really being here or not?
我们当时就觉得，不行了，我筋疲力尽了。但你为什么要为其他人做那种事呢？关于你是同性恋这件事，你是这个意思吗？对，对，比如说，如果我走进一个房间，甚至直到今天，我依然残留着一点那种心态，但大部分时候，我不在乎了。这就好比，我必须去确认，因为我已经习惯了，这现在已经融入了我的血液，去观察人们对我走进这个房间作何感想。他们在意我是否真的在这里吗？
No way. I used to do this when I was younger. I remember I was doing an interview and I sat down and there was probably 14 people behind the camera. And I was, I think it was maybe 21. And I started to sweat and I ran away and I started crying. Because this is what I was thinking. I was like, these people probably think I sound stupid. They're going to go home and tell their partners or friends about how much of an idiot I am. And I feel like a horrible interviewer. I just, it used to kill me.
不可能。我年轻的时候也做过这种事。我记得我有一次在接受采访，我坐下来，镜头后面大概有14个人。那时我大概21岁，我开始出汗，然后逃跑并哭了起来。因为当时我是这么想的：这些人可能觉得听起来我很蠢。他们会回家告诉他们的伴侣或朋友我是个多么大的白痴。我觉得自己是个糟糕的采访对象。我只是，这曾经让我痛苦不堪。
Yes, with panic attack. Yeah, I've had that and I couldn't, I couldn't, I was stuck there and it just becomes exponentially more horrific and terrifying because now you're convinced, now they can see that I'm having a panic attack. Now it gets even worse. So it's like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，伴随着恐慌发作。是的，我经历过那个，我动弹不得，我被困在那里，情况变得呈指数级更加可怕和吓人，因为现在你确信了，现在他们能看出我正在恐慌发作。这下情况变得更糟了。所以就像是，哦，对，对，对，对。
It is so, so we have that too, huh? I mean, I still fall back into it, but I've, you know, here and there, but for the most part, I'm like, I really mean this. I'm sure there'll be a lot of listeners like, should the fuckable you know, I really, this is new to me. I don't understand it in that way. I just some everybody's wired difference. I form a parent like when I like when I got this, you know,
确实是这样，所以我们也有那种情况，对吧？我的意思是，我有时还是会陷入其中，但你知道，偶尔会这样，不过大多数时候，我是认真的。我确信会有很多听众觉得，管他呢，你知道，这对我来说真的很新鲜。我并不那样理解它。我只是觉得每个人的思维方式都不同。我形成了一种父母般的……就像我得到这个的时候，你知道，
when I got this you know when I got this Holding up and I was sort of just plain white and I and I faceless body I thought I can thank you everybody But I feel like the older I get the closer I get to our favorite term sexy indifference or or rather better better said a healthy indifference. Where you do care what people think, but you're not, you're not obsessed by it and you're not, you're not pulled around. I will challenge you on that because we're doing it right now today. That is also put on.
当我拿到这个的时候，你知道的，当我把它举起来，它只是一片纯白，没有面孔的身体，我想我可以感谢大家。但我觉得我越老，就越接近我们最喜欢的那个词——性感的冷漠，或者更准确地说，一种健康的冷漠。在这种状态下，你会在乎别人的想法，但你不会对此着迷，也不会被牵着鼻子走。我要对你这句话提出异议，因为我们今天正在这样做。这也是装出来的。
It's not real because if you have to think about the sexy indifference, then it's not organic. Right. No, no, I'm trying to get to that place of, of, of honest and healthy indifference, that it's not organic. Right. No, no, I'm trying to get to that place of honest and healthy indifference where it's just right-sized. You know, where you do care about people, you don't want to be rude, you want to be sensitive if you're going to see the whole another. You just want to see the other. The freedom is when you don't even have to recognize that you do have indifference,
这不是真的，因为如果你必须去思考这种性感的冷漠，那就不是自然的。对。不，不，我正努力达到那种诚实且健康的冷漠境界，让一切恰到好处。你知道的，你会关心别人，不想粗鲁，如果你要面对另一个人，你会希望保持敏感。你只是想看到对方。真正的自由在于，你甚至不需要去意识到自己拥有这种冷漠，
that you're just living. That's the freedom. You're otherwise, you're shackled by the idea of it. It still lives there as an idea. But it's also what we do for a living, right? It's part of our job to be aware of what people think and kind of manipulate that. And like, that's professional liars. And so it was a little bit of a headscrew for me, obviously, still is when I was a kid,
你只是在生活。这就是自由。否则，你会被它的想法所束缚。它作为一个想法依然存在。但这也是我们谋生的手段，对吧？了解人们的想法并对其进行某种操纵是我们的工作的一部分。就像，那是职业骗子。所以对我来说这有点让人脑子错乱，显然，当我还是个孩子的时候，现在依然如此，
when you're trying to figure out who you are and who you're becoming. I can't imagine as a kid. You're training yourself how to fake to be somebody else. It's kind of a little bit more interesting. Do you still think about that Selena? Absolutely. I remember I was talking about this with someone and there was a study that said, the moment you get famous at a certain age, you end up stuck in that area for a while because it stunts your, yes, because it stunts your, your, your dealing with things that no child should be dealing with and criticizing my body or something weird. Like it just, it felt,
当你试图弄清楚你是谁以及你将成为谁时。我无法想象作为一个孩子。你在训练自己如何假装成别人。这有点更有趣。赛琳娜，你还经常想起那件事吗？当然。我记得我曾和某人讨论过这件事，有一项研究表明，在你某个特定的年龄成名后，你最终会有一段时间被困在那个阶段，因为它阻碍了你的……是的，因为它阻碍了你应对那些本不该由孩子去应对的事情，比如批评我的身材或做一些奇怪的事情。就像它只是，感觉，
just, it doesn't feel good. You can't grow privately, like most people do. You know, that. Yeah, so I mean, I don't regret my life, but there's a huge part of me that's like, yeah, I wonder what that would have been like to just be me for a second. So, but this, I'm assuming that, you know,
就是，感觉不太好。你无法像大多数人那样在私下里成长。你知道的，就是那样。是的，所以我的意思是，我不后悔我的生活，但我内心很大一部分会想，是的，我很好奇如果只是做一会儿自己会是什么样子。所以，不过这个，我假设，你知道的，
you've got millions, literally millions of people that admire you more than any of us could probably imagine because of how brave you are, with how honest you are. And that is not going to go away, thank God. I mean, you're a role model, whether you like it or not. Till I run away from everything. No, no, you're not role model, whether you like it or not. Till I run away from everything. No, no, you're not gonna go wherever you go,
你有数百万，真的是数百万的人比我们想象的任何人都更崇拜你，因为你的勇敢，你的诚实。而且谢天神，这是不会消失的。我的意思是，不管你喜不喜欢，你都是个榜样。直到我逃避一切。不，不，不管你喜不喜欢，你都不是榜样。直到我逃避一切。不，不，无论你走到哪里，你都不会去，
you're gonna be there. No, don't take away her out until you run away. If you will. I rode away. But, but I now get it though, Jay, I wanna say, because you just mentioned that, I wanna say that I now get it when I sort of earlier, flippantly when we first started talking about
你会去那里的。不，在逃跑之前不要带她出去。如果你愿意的话。我骑着车离开了。但是，我现在明白了，杰，我想说的是，因为你刚才提到了这一点，我想说的是，我现在明白了，当我之前在我们刚开始谈论时有点轻率地
how many millions of followers you have, I now understand, I get it now, your relationship with that number, with those numbers of people is tricky. And I sort of have a little bit more of an understanding. I really mean that, maybe I'm a slow learner. No, no, it's weird. It's such a bizarre thing. And they give you way too much information. Like they'll they'll tell you how many accounts you'd reached
不管你有几百万粉丝，我现在明白了，我懂了，你与那个数字、与那些人群的关系很微妙。我算是稍微多理解了一点。我是说真的，也许我学东西慢。不，不，这很诡异。这是一件如此离奇的事情。而且他们给你的信息太多了。比如他们会告诉你你触及了多少个账户
and they'll tell you the percentages of women versus male or or button non-variant or whatever it is. It's like I don't need this information. I just want to post a photo and let it be for my fans and move on. And they are definitely attracted to all the things that are very special about you and not to take away from any of that. But I think it is also very indicative of how common it is
他们会告诉你女性与男性或是性别不变等百分比。就像我不需要这些信息。我只想发张照片交给粉丝然后继续前进。而他们绝对被你身上所有独特的东西所吁引，而不是要拿走其中的任何东西。但我认为这也很能说明这种现象有多常见
for people around the world to be not perfect. And I think they really are comforted by how you are so honest about how not perfect you are. And I think that's just a real gift that you give to people and myself included. I thank you for that. I cannot believe we're already past an hour. But literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. Not an hour. Yeah, but literally the fastest interview. Yeah, I'm stunned. Not an hour right now, but it is pretty crazy. Yeah.
让世界各地的人们接受不完美。我觉得他们真的从你对自身不完美的坦诚中感到了慰藉。我认为这是你送给人们以及包括我自己在内的一份真正的礼物。我为此感谢你。我真不敢相信我们已经聊了一个多小时了。但这绝对是最快的一次采访。是的，我很震惊。不是一个小时。是的，但这绝对是最快的一次采访。是的，我很震惊。现在不是一个小时，但这确实挺疯狂的。是的。
I'm like, right? I'm like, right? I want to punch. Yeah. I want to let you go, but I know we have probably a couple of more questions. Sure, and go. Yes, no, I just want to know only murderers.
我想说，对吧？我想说，对吧？我想打人。是的。我想让你走，但我知道我们可能还有几个问题。当然，请继续。是的，不，我只想知道是不是只有凶手。
I love the show. I love you in it. I love Stephen Marty. How did it come about? What was it like when you started? Did you just love murderers? How you got in? To be honest, yes. And I like very dark documentaries sometimes. So I tend to like lean into those especially scary stuff mentally. And John Hoffman is one of my very good. So but no, it actually happened because,
我非常喜欢这部剧。我也很喜欢你在里面的表演。我喜欢斯蒂芬·马丁。这是怎么开始的？你刚开始的时候感觉怎么样？你只是单纯喜欢杀人犯吗？你是怎么加入的？说实话，是的。而且我有时也喜欢非常黑暗的纪录片。所以我往往会倾向于那些尤其是吓人的心理内容。约翰·霍夫曼是我非常好的朋友。所以，不，其实事情的起因是这样的，
well, Steve's original idea was that it was going to be three men. And then John Hoffman suggested that they hired, yes, who created the show. He said, I think it would be really cool if we added like a younger character, maybe a female. And Steve liked the idea. And I guess this was really a gift
嗯，史蒂夫最初的想法是设定为三个男人。然后约翰·霍夫曼建议他们雇佣——是的，也就是该节目的创作者。他说，我觉得如果我们加入一个年轻的角色，也许是个女性，会非常酷。史蒂夫很喜欢这个想法。我想这确实是一个天才之举
because they had me in mind. And I remember thinking, I'm like, okay, well, what does this mean? And then I had FaceTime with all of them. I went Steve, Marty and John and producers, and I was like, oh, I just have to do this because simply the people are amazing. And then success of it after. It's a good hang. Yeah. And then the success after was just such a, like, surprise and we just were happy to do it.
因为他们想到了我。我记得当时在想，心想，好吧，这代表什么？然后我和他们所有人进行了FaceTime视频。史蒂夫、马蒂、约翰还有制片人都在，我就觉得，哦，我一定要接下这个，因为大家真的太棒了。后来取得的成功嘛。大家在一起很开心。对。然后之后的成功简直是个巨大的惊喜，我们都很高兴能参与其中。
That only murders in the building. Never man slutters. Never man slutters. Never man slutters. Okay. Okay. I'm fine. I'm allowed to ask. Yes, you are. And that is in its fourth year or fifth year coming up on the
那是《大楼里只有谋杀》。绝不是“荡妇”。绝不是“荡妇”。绝不是“荡妇”。好吧。好吧。我很好。我可以问的。是的，你可以。这部剧已经拍到第四季还是第五季了
fifth. We just got renewed for season four season four. And I may we may have to cut this, but John asked John. I was like, how how many more seasons? And he goes, why ask Steve? And Steve said forever. I know he does. My favorite thing about Steve and he knows that I've said this before, but my favorite thing is Steve will be like, I've got to get, I've got to get home. I've got to get home. I've got to go. I'm too old for this. And then I'll be like, that'll be like, well, I go Steve, like how many seasons?
第五季。我们刚刚续订了第四季第四季。也许我们可以剪掉这段，但约翰问过约翰。我当时问，还有多少季？他回了一句，去问史蒂夫。史蒂夫说永远。我知道他会这么说。我最喜欢史蒂夫的一点——他也知道我以前说过这个——我最喜欢的是，史蒂夫总是会说，我得回家了，我得回家了。我得走了。我老得干不动这个了。然后我就会说，我问史蒂夫，到底还有多少季？
He's like, oh, I don't want to stop. We're going to keep going. And I'm like, yeah, you just have to get home. Exactly. But you need to be home. So sometimes I'll be like, I'll carry the load because it is the greatest trio, but as it has been said before, one of the oddest trios. Yeah. And it's so awesome. Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Awesome. Yeah. Great. Well, Selena, this has been great. Thank you, honey, for being here. Of course, I just wanted to tell you, Jason, really quick. Yes, ma'am.
他就会说，哦，我不想停下来。我们要继续拍下去。我就想，好吧，你只是得回家而已。确实如此。但你得回家。所以有时我会想，我来挑大梁吧，因为这是最棒的三人组，但正如以前所说，这也是最奇怪的三人组之一。对。而且太棒了。对。太棒了。对。太棒了。对。太好了。好了，赛琳娜，这次真的太棒了。谢谢你，亲爱的，能来这里。当然，我只想对你说，杰森，就一小会儿。好的，女士。
I am going to send your wife Amanda and your girls some of my new collection from Rare Beauty. And like a whole little box because I would love to see, you know, what they thought or I love. There are enormous fans of yours as is Amanda, my wife. Yay. So I can, I want to send you that because this is going to be, this is going to be one of the biggest collections that I've released and I'm beyond stoked for it. I know it's, it's little things like that that make me happy because.
我打算给你妻子阿曼达和你的女儿们寄一些我Rare Beauty的新系列产品。还有一小整盒，因为我很想看看，你知道的，她们会有什么感想，或者我很喜欢。她们是你的超级粉丝，我妻子阿曼达也是。太好了！所以我想把这些寄给你，因为这将会是，这将会是我发布过规模最大的系列产品之一，我对此感到无比兴奋。我知道，就是这些小事情让我感到快乐，因为
Yeah, but it's, it's not a little thing. It's really impressive what you've done with this. It's this company is potentially, if it's not already bigger than anything you've done in music or in film or television or in social media. I mean, it's an enormous company and you really should be proud of that.
对，但这可不是小事。你用这个品牌取得的成就真的太令人印象深刻了。这个公司很有潜力，如果它现在还不是的话，可能会比你在音乐、电影、电视或社交媒体上做过的任何事情都要大。我的意思是，这是一个庞大的公司，你真的应该为此感到骄傲。
But I think it's good products and we also just try not to be everything else. You know, like I'm not huge on promoting like crazy, you know, makeup. I love makeup, but I want my line to represent yourself and to have fun with it. And it seems very consistent with you and what you represent. Well, my, I share your skin as long flawless. Oh, my, a nice bowl. Thank you. Uh-huh.
但我觉得这是因为产品好，而且我们只是尽量不去做到面面俱到。你知道的，比如我不喜欢疯狂地去宣传什么化妆品。我喜欢化妆，但我希望我的产品线能展现真实的自我，并且能从中获得乐趣。这与你以及你所代表的形象非常契合。嗯，我，我和你的皮肤一样完美无瑕。哦，天哪，真会说话。谢谢你。嗯哼。
That's you. She takes out her glasses. She goes cross side. She did a rich and early. Oh, yeah. What does it say? It's where? It's a little bit confused.
那就是你。她摘下眼镜。她变成斗鸡眼了。她刚才表现得很成熟。哦， yeah。上面写着什么？在哪？有点糊涂。
And then that could look at that beautiful. So she let her say it's where? Say it. Ready and action. No, where? I swear. Oh, my God, that's good. That's really good.
然后那看起来多美啊。所以她让她说，在哪？说吧。准备，开始。不，在哪？我发誓。哦，天哪，太棒了。真的太棒了。
You look just like Richard Herlock. Great. Selene, you're the greatest. I think I so much for doing this. This is a big, big get for us. It's so awesome to be able to. I am so happy and hopefully I'll get to meet you all in person. I'm sure I'll run into you, Jason.
你看起来就像理查德·赫洛克。太棒了。赛琳娜，你太棒了。非常感谢你来做客。对我们来说，能请到你真的是个天大的好消息。太棒了能。我太高兴了，希望我能有机会亲自见见你们大家。我肯定会遇到你的，杰森。
I'm just, I'm a big fan of all of you. And I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm run into you, Jason. I'm just my big fan of all of you, and I've really been wanting to do this for a while. I'm sure you know, Jason. So this has been really great. Thank you. Yeah, for doing you. All right. Have a great, great rest of the day.
我只是，我是你们所有人的超级粉丝。我真的很想做这个很久了。我肯定会遇到你的，杰森。我只是，我是你们所有人的超级粉丝，我真的很想做这个很久了。我确信你懂的，杰森。所以这次真的很棒。谢谢。谢谢你的配合。好的，祝你余下的时光过得非常愉快。
And thanks for talking with us. Yeah. Bye, guys. All right. Bye, Selena. Thank you. You see, now, guys, there's a nice person. You guys have asked me multiple times.
谢谢你跟我们聊天。好，再见，伙计们。好的，再见，赛琳娜。谢谢你。你看，现在，伙计们，多好的人啊。你们问过我好多次了。
You say, you say, you say, Jason, how do I get, how can I become nice? How can I become nicer, you know, and be pleasant? Have success, right? Isn't that you're a theory? You do have success, but then after that, you did try to be not before. Not before, because then they're going to be accused
你们说，你们说，你们说，杰森，我该怎么做，我怎样才能变得善良？我怎么才能变得更讨人喜欢，你知道的，态度好一点？取得成功，对吧？难道这不是你的理论吗？你确实取得了成功，但在这之后，你确实努力在表现得——而不是之前。不是之前，因为那样的话他们就会被指控
of trying to and is gentle as loving as you know, okay? What is that? Will's holding up a fake award. This is my dressing room. I don't know. It's just something like and it looks like an award. It does. It looks like an ask.
在刻意表现，而且要像你知道的那样温和、充满爱意，好吗？那是什么？威尔正拿着一个假奖杯。这是我的化妆室。我不知道。这就像是什么东西，看起来像个奖杯。确实。看起来像个奖项。
I, um, yeah, she's really true. Yeah, no, she's what did you both? Did you learn anything you guys? I did. I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah. I think. Well, a lazy because she's just did you both, did you learn anything you guys? I did. I feel like I'm lazy. Yeah. I think. Well, a lazy because she's just so it seems like everything she does, she's successful
我，嗯，是的，她真的很真实。不，她你们俩呢？你们学到了什么吗，伙计们？我学到了。我觉得我很懒。对。我觉得。好吧，很懒，因为她只是——你们俩呢，你们学到了什么吗，伙计们？我学到了。我觉得我很懒。对。我觉得。好吧，很懒，因为她只是——所以看起来她做的每件事都很成功
at even even mental health. Right. She's successful at that. Right. Right. Because she's not running from it. She's going right through it. She's just.
甚至连心理健康也是如此。对吧。她在处理这个时也很成功。对吧。对吧。因为她没有逃避。她迎难而上。她只是。
It's it's pretty remarkable. And she's so she's such, talk about we were talking authenticity was a central trend today. And she's so authentic. She's like, I'm just a superhero. Really doesn't, like she said, she just does what she loves to do. Everybody's welcome to come or don't come.
这相当了不起。而且她真的，说到我们刚才谈到的，真实性是今天的一个核心趋势。她就是这么真实。她就像是，我只是个超级英雄。真的不，就像她说的，她只是做她喜欢做的事。大家欢迎来看，或者不来都行。
Like, you know, it's funny. I was gonna say, she said that she didn't care, but it's almost like she, it's not that she doesn't care. It feels like she just, what she cares about is just being herself and being. Yeah. And what she turned that care internal, she's taking care of number one, which for me,
你知道，这很有趣。我本来想说，她说她不在乎，但这感觉不像是她不在乎，感觉她所关心的只是做她自己，并且。对。当她把这种关心转向内在时，她是在照顾好最重要的那个人，对我和我来说，
always lets me be a better person to the people around me. Sometimes I over index in the selfishness, but I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry. No. Still rolling. I'm trying to get the right balance. Yeah. Yeah. No, sorry. No. Still rolling.
这总是让我能更好地对待周围的人。有时我在自私上有点过度了，但我正在努力找到正确的平衡点。对。对。不，抱歉。不。还在录音。我正在努力找到正确的平衡点。对。对。不，抱歉。不。还在录音。
Let's get one more of those. Well, a little more convincing. Oh, no, Jason. I was, I held up on so many because it was such such, so many things I wanted to throw in and I didn't because it was just at a respect. It's so nice. Oh, so you've got some unused jokes you'd like to more chop up real quick? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, to work out real quick. No, no, no, no, no, no, there's one at the end certainly that I wanted. Yeah, let's hear it.
让我们再录一个。呃，更有说服力一点。哦，不，杰森。我，我忍住了很多梗，因为有太多，太多我想加进去的东西，但我没有，因为出于尊重。太好了。哦，所以你还有一些没用上的笑话想快速理一理？不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，想快速理一理。不，不，不，不，不，不，最后那个我绝对想用。好，说来听听。
Don't worry, I'll carry the load Steve. And I was like, Sean, how many time? Okay. So, do you want to know, right? Steve, right? Steve, right. Do you want to know though? I, speaking about Archie, your son.
别担心，史蒂夫，我来挑大梁。当时我就说，肖恩，多少次？好吧。所以，你想知道对吧？史蒂夫，对吧？史蒂夫，对吧。不过你想知道吗？我，说到阿奇，你的儿子。
Oh, here we go. He's, this is my. No, this is why. Outside, once I had a wizard crawl at my pants. Now, was it really? Did you really? Yeah, truly, it crawled. It crawled a wizard crawl there.
哦，开始了吧。他是，这是我的。不，这就是为什么。在外面，有一次一只蜥蜴爬进了我的裤腿。真的吗？真的吗？对，千真万确，它在爬。它就那样爬了进去。
And how hard did it get up before it pulled a quick 180 and said, no, thank you. Now, that's such a funny thing wizard. You can do this for so many things. Oh, you know what? Okay. So part of my, part of my, what is he called? The Gay Tray?
它爬得多高才猛地来个180度大转弯说，不，谢谢？天哪，这是个多有趣的梗，蜥蜴。你可以把这个用在好多事情上。哦，你知道吗？好吧。所以我的，我的，那叫什么来着？那副“基佬托盘”？
That Jason called it? Oh, yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, sorry. It's a gay tray, it's an invisalign thing. Yeah. I didn't know you had it in today. Yeah. So I have it in all everyday and then but I can whiten my teeth. But my dentist on three days ago
杰森管它叫什么来着？哦，对，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，对不起。那是隐形牙套的托盘，是隐适美的东西。对。我不知道你今天戴着它。对。所以我每天都戴着它，不过我可以用来给牙齿美白。但我的牙医在三天前
said you care some teeth whitening stuff you could put in the in business line trays. And but you you don't have to put them in the back where the by My Cuspids are by Smart. Smart. Smart. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. If you like Smart List, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wundry Plus in the Wundry app or on Apple Podcasts.
说过，你带了一些牙齿美白剂，可以把它放进隐适美的牙托里。但是你不需要把它放到后面靠近我的尖牙的地方。智能。智能。Smartless由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔贾维和贝内特·巴尔伯科100%有机手工打造。如果你喜欢Smartless，现在就可以通过Wondry App或苹果播客加入Wondry Plus，抢先收听无广告版。
Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. There is nothing more joyous than the holidays. Joyous! Did you say joyous? There is nothing joyous about Christmas. Anyways, I have such great memories with my family decorating, listening to holiday music
Prime会员可以在亚马逊音乐上免广告收听。在你离开之前，请在Wondry.com/survey填写简短问卷，告诉我们你的想法。没有什么比节日更欢乐的了。欢乐！你刚才说欢乐吗？圣诞节根本没什么好欢乐的。总之，我和家人一起装饰、听节日音乐，
and watching Christmas movies. Sounds like a lot of noise, noise, noise to me. Oh, hey, well, he's already interrupted my interest, so I guess I can reveal our next guest. The Grinch, anything you want to tell our listeners? Well, yes, actually, I have a new podcast. From Wondery, Tis the Grinch Holiday talk show is a pathetic attempt by the people of O'Vill to use my situation as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch!
看圣诞电影，留下了如此美好的回忆。听起来对我来说全都是噪音、噪音、噪音。哦，嘿，好吧，他已经打断了我的兴致，那我只好揭晓我们的下一位嘉宾了。格林奇，有什么想对我们的听众说吗？好吧，事实上，我有了一个新播客。来自Wondry的《格林奇捣蛋假日脱口秀》，这是胡村的人试图利用我的遭遇作为一个具有教育意义的时刻而做出的可悲尝试。所以加入我吧，格林奇！
Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire. Your family will love the show! As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondering app or wherever you get your podcasts. you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grand Choliday Talk Show on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听我发起一场反对圣诞节欢乐的运动，像在明火上烤栗子一样拷问名人嘉宾。你的家人一定会喜欢这个节目的！如你所知，我向来以擅长和小孩子相处闻名。在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《格林奇捣蛋假日脱口秀》。你知道的，我向来以擅长和小孩子相处闻名。在Wondry App或你获取播客的任何地方关注《格林奇捣蛋假日脱口秀》。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。